[Music]
gildan media presents
your coach in a box
[Music]
affordable
mind enriching programs
gildan media presents
ikigai
the japanese secret to a long and happy
life
written by hector garcia and francesc
miraes
translated by heather cleary
read by walter dixon
prologue
ikigai
a mysterious word
this audiobook first came into being on
a rainy night in tokyo when its authors
sat down together for the first time in
one of the city's tiny bars
we had each read each other's work but
had never met thanks to the thousands of
miles that separate barcelona from the
capital of japan
then a mutual acquaintance put us in
touch launching a friendship that led to
this project and seems destined to last
a lifetime
the next time we got together a year
later we strolled through a park in
downtown tokyo and ended up talking
about trends in western psychology
specifically logotherapy which helps
people find their purpose in life
we remarked that viktor frankl's logo
therapy had gone out of fashion among
practicing therapists who favored other
schools of psychology though people
still search for meaning in what they do
and how they live
we ask ourselves things like what is the
meaning of my life
is the point just to live longer or
should i seek a higher purpose
why do some people know what they want
and have a passion for life while others
languish in confusion
at some point in our conversation the
mysterious word ikigai came up
this japanese concept which translates
roughly as the happiness of always being
busy is like logo therapy but it goes a
step beyond
it also seems to be one way of
explaining the extraordinary longevity
of the japanese especially on the island
of okinawa where there are 24.55 people
over the age of 100 for every 100 000
inhabitants far more than the global
average
those who study why the inhabitants of
this island in the south of japan live
longer than people anywhere else in the
world believe that one of the keys in
addition to a healthful diet a simple
life in the outdoors green tea and the
sub-tropical climate its average
temperature temperatures like that of
hawaii is the icky guy that shapes their
lives
while researching this concept we
discovered that not a single book in the
fields of psychology or personal
development is dedicated to bringing
this philosophy to the west
is ikigai the reason there are more
centenarians in okinawa than anywhere
else
how does it inspire people to stay
active until the very end
what is the secret to a long and happy
life
as we explored the matter further we
discovered that one place in particular
oguimi a rural town on the north end of
the island with a population of three
thousand boasts the highest life
expectancy in the world a fact that is
earned at the nickname of the village of
longevity
okinawa is where most of japan's
shikawasa a limelike fruit that packs an
extraordinary antioxidant punch comes
from
could that be ogimi's secret to long
life
or is it the purity of the water used to
brew its moringa tea
we decided to go study the secrets of
the japanese centenarians in person
after a year of preliminary research we
arrived in the village where residents
speak an ancient dialect and practice an
animist religion that features
long-haired forest sprites called
bunagaya with our cameras and recording
devices in hand
as soon as we arrived we could sense the
incredible friendliness of its residents
who laughed and joked incessantly amid
lush green hills fed by crystalline
waters
as we conducted our interviews with the
eldest residents of the town we realized
that something far more powerful than
just these natural resources was at work
an uncommon joy flows from its
inhabitants and guides them through the
long and pleasurable journey of their
lives
again the mysterious icky guy
but what is it exactly how do you get it
it never cease to surprise us that this
haven of nearly eternal life was located
precisely in okinawa where two hundred
thousand innocent lives were lost at the
end of world war two
rather than harbor animosity toward
outsiders however okinawans live by the
principle of ichariba chode
a local expression that means treat
everyone like a brother even if you've
never met them before
it turns out that one of the secrets to
happiness of ogimi's residents is
feeling like part of a community
from an early age they practice yuui
ma'aru or teamwork and so are used to
helping one another
nurturing friendships eating light
getting enough rest and doing regular
moderate exercise are all part of the
equation of good health
but at the heart of the joada vivre that
inspires these centenarians to keep
celebrating birthdays and cherishing
each new day is their ikigai
the purpose of this audiobook is to
bring the secrets of japan's
centenarians to you and give you the
tools to find your own ikigai because
those who discover their ikigai have
everything they need for a long and
joyful journey through life
happy travels
hector garcia and francesc mirais
chapter one
ikigai
the art of staying young while growing
old
what is your reason for being
according to the japanese everyone has
an ikigai what a french philosopher
might call a raison d'etre
some people have found their ikigai
while others are still looking though
they carry it within them
our ikigai is hidden deep inside each of
us and finding it requires a patient
search
according to those born on okinawa the
island with the most centenarians in the
world our ikigai is the reason we get up
in the morning
ikigai can be described as the common
ground you find between what you're good
at
what you love
what the world needs and what you can be
paid for
whatever you do don't retire
having a clearly defined ikigai brings
satisfaction happiness and meaning to
our lives
the purpose of this audiobook is to help
you find yours and to share insights
from japanese philosophy on the lasting
health of body mind and spirit one
surprising thing you notice living in
japan is how active people remain after
they retire
in fact many japanese people never
really retire they keep doing what they
love for as long as their health allows
there is in fact no word in japanese
that means retire in the sense of
leaving the workforce for good as in
english
according to dan buettner a national
geographic reporter who knows the
country well
having a purpose in life is so important
in japanese culture that our idea of
retirement simply doesn't exist there
the island of almost eternal youth
certain longevity studies suggest that a
strong sense of community and a clearly
defined ikigai are just as important as
the famously healthful japanese diet
perhaps even more so
recent medical studies of centenarians
from okinawa and other so-called blue
zones the geographic regions were people
live longest provide a number of
interesting facts about these
extraordinary human beings
not only do they live much longer than
the rest of the world's population they
also suffer from fewer chronic illnesses
such as cancer and heart disease
inflammatory disorders are also less
common
many of these centenarians enjoy
enviable levels of vitality and health
that would be unthinkable for people of
advanced age elsewhere
their blood tests reveal fewer free
radicals which are responsible for
cellular aging as a result of drinking
tea and eating until their stomachs are
only 80 percent full
women experience more moderate symptoms
during menopause and both men and women
maintain higher levels of sexual
hormones until much later in life
the rate of dementia is well below the
global average
though we'll consider each of these
findings over the course of the
audiobook research clearly indicates
that the okinawans focus on ikigai gives
a sense of purpose to each and every day
and plays an important role in their
health and longevity
the characters behind ikigai
in japanese ikigai is written by
combining a character which means life
with another which means to be
worthwhile
and that can be broken down to the
characters which mean armor
number one and to be the first to head
into battle taking initiative as a
leader and another character which means
beautiful or elegant
the five blue zones
okinawa holds first place among the
world's blue zones
in okinawa women in particular live
longer and have fewer diseases than
anywhere else in the world
the five regions identified and analyzed
by dan buettner in his book the blue
zones are
1.
okinawa japan
especially the northern part of the
island
the locals either died rich in
vegetables and tofu typically served on
small plates
in addition to their philosophy of
ikigai the moai or close-knit group of
friends plays an important role in their
longevity
two
sardinia italy
specifically the provinces of nuoro and
ogliostra
locals on this island consume plenty of
vegetables and one or two glasses of
wine per day
as in okinawa the cohesive nature of
this community is another factor
directly related to longevity
three
loma linda california
researchers studied a group of
seventh-day adventists who are among the
longest living people in the united
states
four
the nicoya peninsula costa rica
locals remain remarkably active after
90.
many of the region's older residents
have no problem getting up at 5 30 in
the morning to work in the fields
5.
icaria
greece one of every three inhabitants of
this island near the coast of turkey is
over 90 years old compared to less than
one percent of the population of the
united states a fact that is earned at
the nickname of the island of long life
the local secret seems to be a lifestyle
that dates back to 500 bc
in the following chapters we'll examine
several factors that seem to be the keys
to longevity and are found across the
blue zones paying special attention to
okinawa and its so-called village of
longevity
first however it's worth pointing out
that three of these regions are islands
where resources can be scarce and
communities have to help one another
for many helping others might be an
ikigai strong enough to keep them alive
according to scientists who have studied
the five blue zones the keys to
longevity are
diet
exercise
finding a purpose in life an ikigai and
forming strong social ties that is
having a broad circle of friends and
good family relations
members of these communities manage
their time well in order to reduce
stress
consume little meat or processed foods
and drink alcohol in moderation
they don't do strenuous exercise but
they do move every day taking walks and
working in their vegetable gardens
people in the blue zones would rather
walk than drive
gardening which involves daily low
intensity movement is a practice almost
all of them have in common
the 80 percent secret
one of the most common sayings in japan
is harahachibu
which is repeated before or after eating
and means something like fill your belly
to 80 percent
ancient wisdom advises against eating
until we are full
this is why okinawans stop eating when
they feel their stomachs reach 80
percent of their capacity rather than
overeating and wearing down their bodies
with long digestive processes that
accelerate cellular oxidation
of course there's no way to know
objectively if your stomach is at eighty
percent capacity
the lesson to learn from the saying is
that we should stop eating when we're
starting to feel full
the extra side dish the snack we eat
when we know in our hearts we don't
really need it the apple pie after lunch
all these will give us pleasure in the
short term but not having them will make
us happier in the long term
the way food is served is also important
by presenting their meals on many small
plates the japanese tend to eat less
a typical meal in a restaurant in japan
is served in five plates on a tray four
of them very small and the main dish
slightly bigger
having five plates in front of you makes
it seem like you're going to eat a lot
but what happens most of the time is
that you end up feeling slightly hungry
this is one of the reasons why
westerners in japan typically lose
weight and stay trim
recent studies by nutritionists reveal
that okinawans consume a daily average
of one thousand eight hundred to one
thousand nine hundred calories compared
to two thousand two hundred to three
thousand three 300 in the united states
and have a body mass index between 18
and 22 compared to 26 or 27 in the
united states
the okinawan diet is rich in tofu sweet
potatoes fish three times per week and
vegetables roughly 11 ounces per day
in the chapter dedicated to nutrition
we'll see which healthy antioxidant rich
foods are included in this 80 percent
connected for life
it is customary in okinawa to form close
bonds within local communities
a moai is an informal group of people
with common interests who look out for
one another for many serving the
community becomes part of their ikigai
the moai has its origins in hard times
when farmers would get together to share
best practices and help one another cope
with meager harvests
members of a moai make a set monthly
contribution to the group
this payment allows them to participate
in meetings dinners games of go and
shogi japanese chess or whatever hobby
they have in common
the funds collected by the group are
used for activities but if there's money
left over one member decided on a
rotating basis receives a set amount
from the surplus
in this way being part of a moai helps
maintain emotional and financial
stability
if a member of a moai is in financial
trouble he or she can get an advance
from the group's savings
while the details of each moai's
accounting practices vary according to
the group and its economic means the
feeling of belonging and support gives
the individual a sense of security and
helps increase life expectancy
following this brief introduction to the
topics covered in this audio book we
look at a few causes of premature aging
in modern life and then explore
different factors related to ikigai
chapter 2
anti-aging secrets
little things that add up to a long and
happy life
aging's escape velocity and the rabbit
imagine a sign far off in the future
with a number on it that represents the
age of your death
every year that you live you advance
closer to the sign
when you reach the sign you die
now imagine a rabbit holding the sign
and walking to the future
every year that you live the rabbit is
half a year as far away
after a while you will reach the rabbit
and die
but what if the rabbit could walk at a
pace of one year for every year of your
life
you would never be able to catch the
rabbit and therefore you would never die
the speed at which the rabbit walks to
the future is our technology
the more we advance technology and
knowledge of our bodies the faster we
can make the rabbit walk
aging's escape velocity is the moment at
which the rabbit walks at a pace of one
year per year or faster
and we become immortal
aging's escape velocity
for more than a century we've managed to
add an average of 0.3 years to our life
expectancy every year but what would
happen if we had the technology to add a
year of life expectancy every year
in theory we would achieve biological
immortality having reached aging's
escape velocity
researchers with a night of the future
such as ray kurzweil and aubry du gray
claim that we'll reach this escape
velocity in a matter of decades
other scientists are less optimistic
predicting that we'll reach a limit a
maximum age we won't be able to surpass
no matter how much technology we have
for example some biologists assert that
our cells stop regenerating after about
120 years
active mind
youthful body
there is much wisdom in the classic
saying men's sana in corpore sano a
sound mind and a sound body
it reminds us that both mind and body
are important and that the health of one
is connected to that of the other
it's been shown that maintaining an
active adaptable mind is one of the key
factors in staying young
having a youthful mind also drives you
toward a healthy lifestyle that will
slow the aging process
just as a lack of physical exercise has
negative effects on our bodies and mood
a lack of mental exercise is bad for us
because it causes our neurons and neural
connections to deteriorate and as a
result reduces our ability to react to
our surroundings
this is why it's so important to give
your brain a workout
one pioneer in advocating for mental
exercise is the israeli neuroscientist
[ __ ] breznitz who argues that the
brain needs a lot of stimulation in
order to stay in shape
as he stated in an interview with edward
punset for the spanish television
program
redis there is a tension between what is
good for someone and what they want to
do
this is because people especially older
people like to do things as they've
always done them
the problem is that when the brain
develops ingrained habits it doesn't
need to think anymore
things get done quickly and efficiently
on automatic pilot often in a very
advantageous way
this creates a tendency to stick to
routines and the only way of breaking
these is to confront the brain with new
information
presented with new information the brain
creates new connections and is
revitalized
this is why it's so important to expose
yourself to change even if stepping
outside your comfort zone means feeling
a bit of anxiety
the effects of mental training have been
scientifically demonstrated
according to collins hemingway and
[ __ ] breznitz in their book maximum
brain power challenging the brain for
health and wisdom
mental training is beneficial on many
levels
you begin exercising your brain by doing
a certain task for the first time he
writes and at first it seems very
difficult but as you learn how to do it
the training is already working
the second time you realize that it's
easier not harder to do because you're
getting better at it
this has a fantastic effect on a
person's mood
in and of itself it's a transformation
that affects not only the results
obtained but also his or her self-image
this description of a mental workout
might sound a bit formal but simply
interacting with others playing a game
for example offers new stimuli and helps
prevent the depression that can come
with solitude
our neurons start to age while we're
still in our 20s this process is slowed
however by intellectual activity
curiosity and a desire to learn
dealing with new situations learning
something new every day playing games
and interacting with other people seem
to be essential for anti-aging
strategies for the mind
furthermore a more positive outlook in
this regard will yield greater mental
benefits
stress
accused of killing longevity
many people seem older than they are
research into the causes of premature
aging has shown that stress has a lot to
do with it because the body wears down
much faster during periods of crisis
the american institute of stress
investigated this degenerative process
and concluded that most health problems
are caused by stress
researchers at the heidelberg university
hospital conducted a study in which they
subjected a young doctor to a job
interview which they made even more
stressful by forcing him to solve
complex math problems for 30 minutes
afterward they took a blood sample
what they discovered was that his
antibodies had reacted to stress the
same way they react to pathogens
activating the proteins that trigger an
immune response
the problem is that this response not
only neutralizes harmful agents it also
damages healthy cells leading them to
age prematurely
the university of california conducted a
similar study taking data and samples
from 39 women who had high levels of
stress due to the illness of one of
their children and comparing them to
samples from women with healthy children
and low levels of stress
they found that stress promotes cellular
aging by weakening cell structures known
as telomeres which affect cellular
regeneration and how our cells age
as the study revealed the greater the
stress the greater the degenerative
effects on cells
how does stress work
these days people live at a frantic pace
and in a nearly constant state of
competition
at this fever pitch stress is a natural
response to the information being
received by the body is potentially
dangerous or problematic
theoretically this is a useful reaction
as it helps us survive in hostile
surroundings
over the course of our evolution we have
used this response to deal with
difficult situations and to flee from
predators
the alarm that goes off in our head
makes our neurons activate the pituitary
gland which produces hormones that
release corticotropin which in turn
circulates through the body via the
sympathetic nervous system
the adrenal gland is then triggered to
release adrenaline and cortisol
adrenaline raises our respiratory rate
and pulse and prepares our muscles for
action getting the body ready to react
to perceived danger while cortisol
increases the release of dopamine and
blood glucose which is what gets us
charged up and allows us to face
challenges
these processes are in moderation
beneficial
they help us overcome challenges in our
daily lives
nonetheless the stress to which human
beings are subjected today is clearly
harmful
compare the lives of cave dwellers with
modern humans
cave dwellers were relaxed most of the
time
modern humans work most of the time and
are alert to any and all threats
cave dwellers felt stress only in very
specific situations
modern humans are online or waiting for
notifications from their cell phones 24
hours a day
to cave dwellers the threats were real a
predator could end their lives at any
moment
for modern humans the brain associates
the pain of a cell phone or an email
notification with the threat of a
predator
for cave dwellers high doses of cortisol
and adrenaline at moments of danger kept
the body healthy in modern humans
low doses of cortisol flow constantly
through the body with implications for a
range of health problems including
adrenal fatigue and chronic fatigue
syndrome
stress has a degenerative effect over
time
a sustained state of emergency affects
the neurons associated with memory as
well as inhibiting the release of
certain hormones the absence of which
can cause depression
its secondary effects include
irritability insomnia anxiety and high
blood pressure
as such though challenges are good for
keeping mind and body active we should
adjust our high stress lifestyles in
order to avoid the premature aging of
our bodies
be mindful about reducing stress
whether or not the threats we perceive
are real stress is an easily
identifiable condition that not only
causes anxiety but is also highly
psychosomatic affecting everything from
our digestive system to our skin
this is why prevention is so important
in avoiding the toll that stress takes
on us and why many experts recommend
practicing mindfulness
the central premise of this stress
reduction method is focusing on the self
noticing our responses even if they are
conditioned by habit in order to be
fully conscious of them
in this way we connect with the here and
now and limit thoughts that tend to
spiral out of control
we have to learn to turn off the
autopilot that's steering us in an
endless loop
we all know people who snack while
talking on the phone or watching the
news you ask them if the omelet they
just ate had an onion in it and they
can't tell you
says roberto alcibar
who abandoned his fast-paced life to
become a certified instructor of
mindfulness after an illness threw him
into a period of acute stress
one way to reach such a state of
mindfulness is through meditation which
helps filter the information that
reaches us from the outside world
it can also be achieved through
breathing exercises yoga and body scans
achieving mindfulness involves a gradual
process of training but with a bit of
practice we can learn to focus our mind
completely which reduces stress and
helps us live longer
a little stress is good for you
while sustained intense stress is a
known enemy of longevity and both mental
and physical health low levels of stress
have been shown to be beneficial
after observing a group of test subjects
for more than 20 years dr howard s
friedman a psychology professor at the
university of california riverside
discovered that people who maintained a
low level of stress who faced challenges
and put their heart and soul into their
work in order to succeed
lived longer than those who chose a more
relaxed lifestyle and retired earlier
from this he concluded that a small dose
of stress is a positive thing as those
who live with low levels of stress tend
to develop healthier habits smoke less
and drink less alcohol
given this it's not surprising that many
of the super centenarians people who
live to be 110 or more whom you'll meet
in this audiobook talk about having
lived intense lives and working well
into old age
a lot of sitting will age you
in the western world in particular the
rise in sedentary behavior has led to
numerous diseases such as hypertension
and obesity which in turn affect
longevity
spending too much time seated at work or
at home not only reduces muscular and
respiratory fitness but also increases
appetite and curbs the desire to
participate in activities
being sedentary can lead to hypertension
imbalanced eating cardiovascular disease
osteoporosis and even certain kinds of
cancer
recent studies have shown a connection
between a lack of physical activity and
the progressive distortion of telomeres
in the immune system which ages those
cells and in turn the organism as a
whole
this is a problem at all life stages not
only among adults
sedentary children suffer from high
rates of obesity and all its associated
health issues and risks which is why
it's so important to develop a healthy
and active lifestyle in an early age
it's easy to be less sedentary it just
takes a bit of effort and a few changes
to your routine
we can access a more active lifestyle
that makes us feel better inside and out
we just have to add a few ingredients to
our everyday habits
walk to work or just go on a walk for at
least 20 minutes each day
use your feet instead of an elevator or
escalator
this is good for your posture your
muscles and your respiratory system
among other things
participate in social or leisure
activities so that you don't spend too
much time in front of the television
replace your junk food with fruit and
you'll have less of an urge to snack and
more nutrients in your system
get the right amount of sleep
seven to nine hours is good but any more
than that makes us lethargic
play with children or pets or join a
sports team
this not only strengthens the body but
also stimulates the mind and boosts
self-esteem
be conscious of your daily routine in
order to detect harmful habits and
replace them with more positive ones
by making these small changes we can
begin to renew our bodies and minds and
increase our life expectancy
a model's best kept secret
we age both externally and internally
both physically and mentally one of the
things that tell us the most about
people's age is their skin which takes
on different textures and colors
according to processes going on beneath
the surface
most of those who make their living as
models claim to sleep between nine and
ten hours the night before a fashion
show
this gives their skin a taut
wrinkle-free appearance and a healthy
radiant glow
science has shown that sleep is a key
anti-aging tool because when we sleep we
generate melatonin a hormone that occurs
naturally in our bodies
the pineal gland produces it from the
neurotransmitter serotonin according to
our diurnal and nocturnal rhythms and it
plays a role in our sleep and waking
cycles
a powerful antioxidant melatonin helps
us live longer and also offers the
following benefits
it strengthens the immune system
it contains an element that protects
against cancer it promotes the natural
production of insulin
it slows the onset of alzheimer's
disease
it helps prevent osteoporosis and fight
heart disease
for all these reasons melatonin is a
great ally in preserving youth
it should be noted however that
melatonin production decreases after age
30.
we can compensate for this by
eating a balanced diet and getting more
calcium
soaking up a moderate amount of sun each
day
getting enough sleep
avoiding stress alcohol tobacco and
caffeine all of which make it harder to
get a good night's rest depriving us of
the melatonin we need
experts are trying to determine whether
artificially stimulating production of
melatonin might help slow the aging
process
which would confirm the theory that we
already carry the secret to longevity
within us
anti-aging attitudes
the mind has tremendous power over the
body and how quickly it ages
most doctors agree that the secret to
keeping the body young is keeping the
mind active a key element of ikigai and
not caving in when we face difficulties
throughout our lives
one study conducted at yeshiva
university found that the people who
live the longest have two dispositional
traits in common
a positive attitude and a high degree of
emotional awareness
in other words those who face challenges
with a positive outlook and are able to
manage their emotions are already well
on their way toward longevity
a stoic attitude serenity in the face of
a setback can also help keep you young
as it lowers anxiety and stress levels
and stabilizes behavior
this can be seen in the greater life
expectancies of certain cultures with
unhurried deliberate lifestyles
many centenarians and super centenarians
have similar profiles
they've had full lives that were
difficult at times but they knew how to
approach these challenges with a
positive attitude and not be overwhelmed
by the obstacles they faced
alexander image who in 2014 became the
world's oldest living man at age 11 knew
he had good genes but understood that
other factors contributed too
the life you live is equally or more
important for longevity he said in an
interview with reuters after being added
to guinness world records in 2014
an ode to longevity
during our stay in ogimi the village
that holds the guinness record for
longevity a woman who was about to turn
100 years old sang the following song
for us in a mixture of japanese in the
local dialect
to keep healthy and have a long life eat
just a little of everything with relish
go to bed early get up early and then go
out for a walk
we live each day with serenity and we
enjoy the journey
to keep healthy and have a long life we
get on well with all our friends
spring summer fall winter we happily
enjoy all the seasons
the secret is not to get distracted by
how old the fingers are from the fingers
to the head and back once again
if you keep moving with your fingers
working
100 years will come to you
we can now use our fingers to play the
next chapter where we'll look at the
close relationship between longevity and
discovering our life's mission
chapter 3
from logotherapy to ikigai
how to live longer and better by finding
your purpose
what is logotherapy
a colleague once asked victor frankel to
define his school of psychology in a
single phrase to which frankl replied
well in logotherapy the patient sits up
straight and has to listen to things
that are on occasion hard to hear
the colleague had just described
psychoanalysis to him in the following
terms
in psychoanalysis the patient lies down
on a couch and tells you things that are
on occasion hard to say
frankl explains that one of the first
questions he would ask his patients was
why do you not commit suicide
usually the patient found good reasons
not to and was able to carry on
what then does logotherapy do
the answer is pretty clear
it helps you find reasons to live
logotherapy pushes patients to
consciously discover their life's
purpose in order to confront their
neuroses
their quest to fulfill their destiny
then motivates them to press forward
breaking the mental chains of the past
and overcoming whatever obstacles they
encounter along the way
something to live for
a study conducted by frankel in his
vienna clinic found that among both
patients and personnel around eighty
percent believed that human beings
needed a reason for living and around
sixty percent felt they had someone or
something in their lives worth dying for
the search for meaning
the search for purpose became a personal
driving force that allowed frankl to
achieve his goals
the process of logo therapy can be
summarized in these five steps
one
a person feels empty frustrated or
anxious
two
the therapist shows him that what he is
feeling is the desire to have a
meaningful life
three the patient discovers his life's
purpose at that particular point in time
[Music]
four
of his own free will the patient decides
to accept or reject that destiny
five
this newfound passion for life helps him
overcome obstacles and sorrows
frankel himself would live and die for
his principles and ideals
his experiences as a prisoner at
auschwitz showed him that everything can
be taken from a man but one thing
the last of the human freedoms
to choose one's attitude in any given
set of circumstances to choose one's own
way
it was something he had to go through
alone without any help
and it inspired him for the rest of his
life
10 differences between psychoanalysis
and logotherapy
psychoanalysis
the patient reclines on a couch like a
patient
logotherapy the patient sits facing the
therapist who guides him or her without
passing judgment
psychoanalysis is retrospective it looks
to the past
logotherapy looks toward the future
psychoanalysis is introspective it
analyzes neuroses
logotherapy does not delve into the
patient's neuroses
in psychoanalysis the drive is toward
pleasure
in logotherapy the drive is toward
purpose and meaning
psychoanalysis centers on psychology
logotherapy includes a spiritual
dimension
psychoanalysis works on psychogenic
neuroses
logotherapy also works on noeogenic or
existential neuroses
psychoanalysis analyzes the unconscious
origin of conflicts instinctual
dimension
logotherapy deals with conflicts when
and where they arise spiritual
dimension psychoanalysis limits itself
to the patient's instincts
logotherapy also deals with spiritual
realities
psychoanalysis is fundamentally
incompatible with faith logotherapy is
compatible with faith
psychoanalysis seeks to reconcile
conflicts and satisfy impulses and
instincts
logotherapy seeks to help the patient
find meaning in his life
and satisfy his moral principles
fight for yourself
existential frustration arises when our
life is without purpose or when that
purpose is skewed
in frankl's view however there's no need
to see this frustration as an anomaly or
a symptom of neurosis
instead it can be a positive thing a
catalyst for change
logotherapy does not see this
frustration as mental illness the way
other forms of therapy do but rather as
spiritual anguish
a natural and beneficial phenomenon that
drives those who suffer from it to seek
a cure whether on their own or with the
help of others and in so doing find
greater satisfaction in life
it helps them change their own destiny
logotherapy enters the picture if a
person needs help doing this if he needs
guidance in discovering his life's
purpose and later in overcoming conflict
so we can keep moving towards his
objective
in man's search for meaning frankel
cites one of nietzsche's famous
aphorisms
he who has a why to live can bear with
almost any how
based on his own experience frankel
believed that our health depends on that
natural tension that comes from
comparing what we've accomplished so far
with what we'd like to achieve in the
future
what we need then is not a peaceful
existence but a challenge we can strive
to meet by applying all the skills at
our disposal
existential crisis on the other hand is
typical of modern societies in which
people do what they're told to do or
what others do rather than what they
want to do
they often try to fill the gap between
what is expected of them and what they
want for themselves with economic power
or physical pleasure or by numbing their
senses
it can even lead to suicide
sunday neurosis for example is what
happens when without the obligations and
commitments of the work week the
individual realizes how empty he is
inside
he has to find a solution
above all he has to find his purpose his
reason for getting out of bed is ikigai
i feel empty inside
in a study conducted at the vienna poly
clinic hospital frankel's team found
that 55 percent of the patients they
interviewed were experiencing some
degree of existential crisis
according to logotherapy discovering
one's purpose in life helps an
individual fill that existential void
frankl a man who faced his problems and
turned his objectives into actions could
look back on his life in peace as he
grew old
he did not have to envy those still
enjoying their youth because he had
amassed a broad set of experiences that
showed he had lived for something
better living through logotherapy
a few key ideas
we don't create the meaning of our life
as sartre claimed we discover it
we each have a unique reason for being
which can be adjusted or transformed
many times over the years
just as worry often brings about
precisely the thing that was feared
excessive attention to a desire or hyper
intention can keep that desire from
being fulfilled
humor can help break negative cycles and
reduce anxiety
we all have the capacity to do noble or
terrible things
the side of the equation we end up on
depends on our decisions
not on the condition in which we find
ourselves
in the following case studies we'll look
at four cases from frankel's own
practice in order to better understand
the search for meaning and purpose
case study
victor frankel
in german concentration camps as in
those that would later be built in japan
and korea psychiatrists confirmed that
the prisoners with the greatest chance
of survival were those who had things
they wanted to accomplish outside the
camp
those who felt a strong need to get out
of there alive
this was true of frankel who after being
released and successfully developing the
school of logotherapy realized he had
been the first patient of his own
practice
frankel had a goal to achieve and it
made him persevere
he arrived at auschwitz carrying a
manuscript that contained all the
theories and research he compiled over
the course of his career ready for
publication
when it was confiscated he felt
compelled to write it all over again
and that need drove him and gave his
life meaning amid the constant horror
and doubt of the concentration camp
so much so that over the years and
especially when he fell ill with typhus
he would jot down fragments and key
words from the lost work on any scrap of
paper he found
case study
the american diplomat
an important north american diplomat
went to frankel to pick up where he left
off with a course of treatment he had
started five years earlier in the united
states
when frankl asked him why he'd started
therapy in the first place the diplomat
answered that he hated his job and his
country's international policies which
he had to follow and enforce
his american psychoanalyst whom he'd
been seeing for years insisted he make
peace with his father so that his
government and his job both
representations of the paternal figure
would seem less disagreeable
frankel however showed him in just a few
sessions that his frustration was due to
the fact that he wanted to pursue a
different career
and the diplomat concluded his treatment
with that idea in mind
five years later the former diplomat
informed frankel that he'd been working
during that time in a different
profession and that he was happy
in frankel's view the man not only
didn't need all those years of
psychoanalysis
he also couldn't even really be
considered a patient in native therapy
he was simply someone in search of a new
life's purpose
as soon as he found it his life took on
deeper meaning
case study
the suicidal mother
the mother of a boy who had died at age
11 was admitted to frankl's clinic after
she tried to kill herself and her other
son
it was this other son paralyzed since
birth who kept her from carrying out her
plan
he did believe his life had a purpose
and if his mother killed them both it
would keep him from achieving his goals
the woman shared her story in a group
session
to help her frankel asked another woman
to imagine a hypothetical situation in
which she lay on her deathbed old and
wealthy but childless
the woman insisted that in that case she
would have felt her life had been a
failure
when the suicidal mother was asked to
perform the same exercise imagining
herself on her deathbed she looked back
and realized that she had done
everything in her power for her children
for both of them
she had given her paralyzed son a good
life
and he had turned into a kind reasonably
happy person
to this she added crying
as for myself
i can look back peacefully on my life
for i can say my life was full of
meaning and i have tried hard to live it
fully
i have done my best i've done my best
for my son
my life was no failure
in this way by imagining herself on her
deathbed and looking back
the suicidal mother found the meaning
that though she was not aware of it her
life already had
case study
the grief-stricken doctor
an elderly doctor unable to overcome the
deep depression into which he'd fallen
after the death of his wife two years
earlier went to frankel for help
instead of giving him advice or
analyzing his condition frankel asked
him what would have happened if he had
been the one who died first
the doctor horrified answered that it
would have been terrible for his poor
wife that she would have suffered
tremendously
to which frankl responded
you see doctor you've spared her all
that suffering but the price you have to
pay for this is to survive
and mourn her
the doctor didn't say another word
he left frankel's office in peace after
taking the therapist's hand in his own
he was able to tolerate the pain in
place of his beloved wife
his life had been given a purpose
morita therapy
in the same decade that logotherapy came
into being a few years earlier in fact
shoma morita created his own
purpose-centered therapy in japan
it proved to be effective in the
treatment of neurosis
obsessive-compulsive disorder and
post-traumatic stress
in addition to being a psychotherapist
shoma morita was a zen buddhist and his
therapy left a lasting spiritual mark on
japan
many western forms of therapy focus on
controlling or modifying the patient's
emotions
in the west we tend to believe that what
we think influences how we feel which in
turn influences how we act
in contrast morita therapy focuses on
teaching patients to accept their
emotions without trying to control them
since their feelings will change as a
result of their actions
in addition to accepting the patient's
emotions morita therapy seeks to create
new emotions on the basis of actions
according to marita these emotions are
learned through experience and
repetition
morita therapy is not meant to eliminate
symptoms instead it teaches us to accept
our desires anxieties fears and worries
and let them go
as morita writes in his book morita
therapy and the true nature of
anxiety-based disorders
in feelings it is best to be wealthy and
generous
marita explained the idea of letting go
of negative feelings with the following
fable
a donkey that is tied to a post by a
rope will keep walking around the post
in an attempt to free itself only to
become more immobilized and attached to
the post
the same thing applies to people with
obsessive thinking who become more
trapped in their own suffering when they
try to escape from their fears and
discomfort
the basic principles of morita therapy
one
accept your feelings
if we have obsessive thoughts we should
not try to control them or get rid of
them
if we do they become more intense
regarding human emotions the zen master
would say
if we try to get rid of one wave with
another we end up with an infinite sea
we don't create our feelings they simply
come to us and we have to accept them
the trick
is welcoming them
morita likened emotions to the weather
we can't predict or control them we can
only observe them to this point he often
quoted the vietnamese monk tic not han
who would say
hello solitude
how are you today
come
sit with me and i will care for you
two
do what you should be doing
we shouldn't focus on eliminating
symptoms because recovery will come on
its own
we should focus instead on the present
moment and if we're suffering on
accepting that suffering
above all we should avoid
intellectualizing the situation
the therapist's mission is to develop
the patient's character so he or she can
face any situation
and character is grounded in the things
we do
morita therapy does not offer its
patients explanations but rather allows
them to learn from their actions and
activities
it doesn't tell you how to meditate or
how to keep a diary the way western
therapies do
it's up to the patient to make
discoveries through experience
three
discover your life's purpose
we can't control our emotions but we can
take charge of our actions every day
this is why we should have a clear sense
of our purpose and always keep morita's
mantra in mind
what do we need to be doing right now
what action should we be taking
the key to achieving this is having
dared to look inside yourself to find
your ikigai
the four phases of morita therapy
morita's original treatment which lasts
15 to 21 days consists of the following
stages
one
isolation and rest
five to seven days
during the first week of treatment the
patient rests in a room without any
external stimuli
no television books family
friends or speaking
all the patient has is his thoughts
he lies down for most of the day and is
visited regularly by the therapist who
tries to avoid interacting with him as
much as possible
the therapist simply advises the patient
to continue observing the rise and fall
of his emotions as he lies there
when the patient gets bored and wants to
start doing things again he's ready to
move on to the next stage of therapy
two
light occupational therapy
five to seven days
in this stage the patient performs
repetitive tasks in silence
one of these is keeping a diary about
his thoughts and feelings
the patient goes outside after a week of
being shut in takes walks in nature and
does breathing exercises
he also starts doing simple activities
such as gardening drawing or painting
during this stage the patient is still
not allowed to talk to anyone except the
therapist
three
occupational therapy five to seven days
in this stage the patient performs tasks
that require physical movement dr marita
like to take his patients to the
mountains to chop wood
in addition to physical tasks the
patient is also immersed in other
activities such as writing painting or
making ceramics
the patient can speak with others at
this stage but only about the tasks at
hand
four
the return to social life and the real
world
the patient leaves the hospital and is
reintroduced to social life but
maintains the practices of meditation
and occupational therapy developed
during treatment
the idea is to re-enter society as a new
person with a sense of purpose and
without being controlled by social or
emotional pressures
nikon meditation
morita was a great zen master of nikon
introspective meditation
much of his therapy draws on his
knowledge and mastery of the school
which centers on three questions the
individual must ask him or herself
one
what have i received from person x
two what have i given to person x
three
what problems have i caused person x
through these reflections we stop
identifying others as the cause of our
problems and deepen our own sense of
responsibility
as morita said
if you are angry and want to fight
think about it for three days before
coming to blows
after three days the intense desire to
fight will pass on its own
and now
ikigai
logotherapy and marita therapy are both
grounded in a personal unique experience
that you can access without therapists
or spiritual retreats
the mission of finding your ikigai your
existential fuel
once you find it it's only a matter of
having the courage and making the effort
to stay on the right path
in the following chapters we'll take a
look at the basic tools you'll need to
get moving along that path
finding flow in the tasks you've chosen
to do
eating in a balanced and mindful way
doing low intensity exercise and
learning not to give in when
difficulties arise
in order to do this you have to accept
that the world like the people who live
in it is imperfect
but that it's still full of
opportunities for growth and achievement
are you ready to throw yourself into
your passion as if it were the most
important thing in the world
chapter four
find flow in everything you do how to
turn work and free time into spaces for
growth
we are what we repeatedly do
excellence then is not an act but a
habit
aristotle
going with the flow
imagine you're skiing down one of your
favorite slopes
powdery snow flies up on both sides of
you like white sand conditions are
perfect you are entirely focused on
skiing as well as you can
you know exactly how to move at each
moment
there is no future no past there is only
the present
you feel the snow your skis your body
and your consciousness united as a
single entity
you are completely immersed in the
experience
not thinking about or distracted by
anything else
your ego dissolves
and you become part of what you're doing
this is the kind of experience bruce lee
described with his famous
be water my friend
we've all felt our sense of time vanish
when we lose ourselves in an activity we
enjoy
we start cooking and before we know it
several hours have passed
we spend an afternoon with a book and
forget about the world going by until we
notice the sunset and realize we haven't
eaten dinner
we go surfing and don't realize how many
hours we've spent in the water until the
next day when our muscles ache
the opposite can also happen when we
have to complete a task we don't want to
do every minute feels like a lifetime
and we can't stop looking at our watch
as the quip attributed to einstein goes
put your hand on a hot stove for a
minute and it seems like an hour
sit with a pretty girl for an hour and
it seems like a minute
that is relativity
the funny thing is that someone else
might really enjoy the same task but we
want to finish as quickly as possible
what makes us enjoy doing something so
much that we forget about whatever
worries we might have while we do it
when are we happiest
these questions can help us discover our
ikigai
the power of flow
these questions are also at the heart of
psychologist mihai chiksan mihai's
research into the experience of being
completely immersed in what we're doing
chick sent me high called this state
flow and described it as the pleasure
delight creativity and process when we
are completely immersed in life
there is no magic recipe for finding
happiness for living according to your
ikigai
but one key ingredient is the ability to
reach the state of flow
and through this state heaven optimal
experience
in order to achieve this optimal
experience we have to focus on
increasing the time we spend on
activities that bring us to this state
of flow rather than allowing ourselves
to get caught up in activities that
offer immediate pleasure like eating too
much abusing drugs or alcohol or
stuffing ourselves with chocolate in
front of the tv
as chicks and mihai asserts in his book
flow
the psychology of optimal experience
flow is
the state in which people are so
involved in an activity that nothing
else seems to matter
the experience itself is so enjoyable
that people will do it even at great
cost for the sheer sake of doing it
it's not only creative professionals who
require the high doses of concentration
that promote flow most athletes chess
players and engineers also spend much of
their time on activities that bring them
to this state
according to chicks and mihai's research
a chess player feels the same way upon
entering a state of flow as a
mathematician working on a formula or a
surgeon performing an operation
a professor of psychology cheeks and
mihi analyzed data from people around
the world and discovered that flow is
the same among individuals of all ages
and cultures
in new york and okinawa we all reach a
state of flow in the same way
but what happens to our mind when we're
in that state
when we flow we're focused on a concrete
task without any distractions our mind
is in order
the opposite occurs when we try to do
something while our mind is on other
things
the seven conditions for achieving flow
according to researcher owen shaffer of
depaul university the requirements for
achieving flow are one
knowing what to do
two knowing how to do it
three
knowing how well you're doing
four knowing where to go where
navigation is involved
five perceiving significant challenges
six
perceiving significant skills
seven
being free from distractions
if you often find yourself losing focus
while working on something you consider
important there are several strategies
you can employ to increase your chances
of
strategy number one
choose a difficult task
but not too difficult
shaffer's model encourages us to take on
tasks that we have a chance of
completing but that are slightly outside
our comfort zone
every task sport or job has a set of
rules and we need a set of skills to
follow them
if the rules for completing a task or
achieving a purpose are too basic
relative to our skill set we'll likely
get bored activities that are too easy
lead to apathy
if on the other hand we assign ourselves
to a task that is too difficult we won't
have the skills to complete it and will
almost certainly give up and feel
frustrated to boot
the ideal is to find a middle path
something aligned with our abilities but
just a bit of a stretch so we experience
it as a challenge
that's what ernest hemingway meant when
he said sometimes i write better than i
can
we want to see challenges through to the
end because we enjoy the feeling of
pushing ourselves
bertrand russell expressed a similar
idea when he said
to be able to concentrate for a
considerable amount of time is essential
to difficult achievement
if you're a graphic designer learn a new
software program for your next project
if you're a programmer use a new
programming language
if you're a dancer try to incorporate
into your next routine a movement that
has seemed impossible for years
add a little something extra something
that takes you out of your comfort zone
even doing something as simple as
reading means following certain rules
having certain abilities and knowledge
if we set out to read a book on quantum
mechanics for specialists in physics
without being specialists in physics
ourselves we'll probably give up after a
few minutes
on the other end of the spectrum if we
already know everything a book has to
tell us we'll get bored right away
however if the book is appropriate to
our knowledge and abilities and builds
on what we already know
we'll immerse ourselves in our reading
and time will flow
this pleasure and satisfaction are
evidence that we are in tune with our
icky guy
in summary easy tasks lead to boredom
challenging tasks lead to flow
tasks beyond our abilities lead to
anxiety
strategy two
have a clear concrete objective
video games played in moderation board
games and sports are great ways to
achieve flow because the objective tends
to be very clear
beat your rival or your own record while
following a set of explicitly defined
rules
unfortunately the objective isn't quite
as clear in most situations
according to a study by boston
consulting group when asked about their
bosses the number one complaint of
employees at multinational corporations
is that they don't communicate the
team's mission clearly
and that as a result the employees don't
know what their objectives are
what often happens especially in big
companies is that the executives get
lost in the details of obsessive
planning creating strategies to hide the
fact that they don't have a clear
objective
it's like heading out to sea with a map
but no destination
it's much more important to have a
compass pointing to a concrete objective
than to have a map
joy ito director of the mit media lab
encourages us to use the principle of
compass over maps as a tool to navigate
our world of uncertainty
in the book whiplash how to survive our
faster future he and jeff howell write
in an increasingly unpredictable world
moving ever more quickly a detailed map
may lead you deep into the woods at an
unnecessarily high cost
a good compass though will always take
you where you need to go
it doesn't mean that you should start
your journey without any idea where
you're going
what it does mean is understanding that
while the path to your goal may not be
straight
you'll finish faster and more
efficiently than you would have if you
would trudged along a pre-planned route
in business the creative professions and
education alike it's important to
reflect on what we hope to achieve
before starting to work study or make
something
we should ask ourselves questions such
as
what is my objective for today's session
in the studio
how many words am i going to write today
for the article coming out next month
what is my team's mission
how fast will i set the metronome
tomorrow in order to play that sonata at
an allegro temple by the end of the week
having a clear objective is important in
achieving flow
but we also have to know how to leave it
behind when we get down to business
once the journey has begun we should
keep this objective in mind without
obsessing over it
when olympic athletes compete for a gold
medal they can't stop to think how
pretty the metal is they have to be
present in the moment
they have to flow if they lose focus for
a second thinking how proud they'll be
to show the medal to their parents
they'll almost certainly commit an error
at a critical moment and will not win
the competition
one common example of this is writer's
block
imagine that a writer has to finish a
novel in three months
the objective is clear
the problem is that the writer can't
stop obsessing over it
every day she wakes up thinking i have
to write that novel and every day she
sets about reading the newspaper and
cleaning the house
every evening she feels frustrated and
promises she'll get to work the next day
days weeks and months pass and the
writer still hasn't gotten anything down
on the page when all it would have taken
was to sit down and get that first word
out then the second
to flow with the project expressing her
icky guy
as soon as you take these first small
steps your anxiety will disappear and
you'll achieve a pleasant flow in the
activity you're doing
getting back to albert einstein
a happy man is too satisfied with the
present to dwell on the future
to summarize a vague objective leads to
confusion time and energy wasted on
meaningless tasks and mental block
a clearly defined objective and a focus
on process leads to flow
and obsessive desire to achieve a goal
while ignoring process leads to a
fixation on the objective rather than on
getting down to business and mental
block
strategy three
concentrate on a single task
this is perhaps one of the greatest
obstacles we face today with so much
technology and so many distractions
we're listening to a video on youtube
while writing an email when suddenly a
chat prompt pops up and we answer it
then our smartphone vibrates in our
pocket
just as soon as we respond to that
message we're back at our computer
logging onto facebook
pretty soon 30 minutes have passed and
we've forgotten what the email we were
writing was supposed to be about
this also happens sometimes when we put
on a movie with dinner and don't realize
how delicious the salmon was until we're
taking the last bite
we often think that combining tasks will
save us time but scientific evidence
shows that it has the opposite effect
even those who claim to be good at
multitasking are not very productive
in fact they are some of the least
productive people
our brains can take in millions of bits
of information but we can only actually
process a few dozen per second
when we say we're multitasking what
we're really doing is switching back and
forth between tasks very quickly
unfortunately we're not computers adept
at parallel processing
we end up spending all our energy
alternating between tasks instead of
focusing on doing one of them well
concentrating on one thing at a time may
be the single most important factor in
achieving flow
according to cheeks and mihi in order to
focus on a task we need one
to be in a distraction-free environment
and two
to have control over what we're doing at
every moment
technology is great if we're in control
of it it's not so great if it takes
control of us
for example if you have to write a
research paper you might sit down at
your computer and use google to look up
the information you need
however if you're not very disciplined
you might end up surfing the web instead
of writing that paper
in that case google and the internet
will have taken over pulling you out of
your state of flow
it has been scientifically shown that if
we continually ask our brains to switch
back and forth between tasks we waste
time make more mistakes and remember
less of what we've done
several studies conducted at stanford
university by clifford ivar nass
describe our generation as suffering
from an epidemic of multitasking
one such study analyzed the behavior of
hundreds of students dividing them into
groups based on the number of things
they tended to do at once
the students who were the most addicted
to multitasking typically alternated
among more than four tasks
for example taking notes while reading a
textbook listening to a podcast
answering messages on their smartphone
and sometimes checking their twitter
timeline
each group of students was shown a
screen with several red and several blue
arrows
the objective of the exercise was to
count the red
arrows at first all the students
answered correctly right away without
much trouble
as the number of blue arrows increased
the number of red arrows stayed the same
only their position changed however the
students accustomed to multitasking had
serious trouble counting the red arrows
in the time allotted or as quickly as
the students who did not habitually
multitask
for one very simple reason
they got distracted by the blue arrows
their brains were trained to pay
attention to every stimulus regardless
of its importance while the brains of
other students were trained to focus on
a single task
in this case counting the red arrows and
ignoring the blue ones
other studies indicate that working on
several things at once lowers our
productivity by at least 60 percent and
our iq by more than 10 points
one study funded by the swedish council
for working life and social research
found that a sample group of more than 4
000 young adults between the ages of 20
and 24 who were addicted to their
smartphones got less sleep
felt less connected to their community
at school and were more likely to show
signs of depression
in summary
concentrating on a single task
makes achieving flow more likely
increases productivity
increases our power of retention
makes us less likely to make mistakes
helps us feel calm and in control of the
task at hand
causes us to become more considerate as
we pay full attention to those around us
and increases creativity
multitasking makes achieving flow
impossible
decreases productivity by sixty percent
though it doesn't seem to
makes it harder to remember things
makes us more likely to make mistakes
makes us feel stressed by the sensation
that we're losing control that our tasks
are controlling us
causes us to hurt those around us
through our addiction to stimuli always
checking our phones always on social
media and reduces creativity
what can we do to avoid falling victim
to this flow impeding epidemic
how can we train our brains to focus on
a single task
here are a few ideas for creating a
space and time free of distractions to
increase our chances of reaching a state
of flow and thereby getting in touch
with our ikigai
don't look at any kind of screen for the
first hour you're awake and the last
hour before you go to sleep
turn off your phone before you achieve
flow
there's nothing more important than the
task you've chosen to do during this
time
if this seems too extreme enable the do
not disturb function so only the people
closest to you contact you in case of
emergency
designate one day of the week perhaps a
saturday or sunday a day of technical
fasting
making exceptions for e-readers without
wi-fi or mp3 players
go to a cafe that doesn't have wi-fi
read and respond to email only once or
twice per day
define those times clearly and stick to
them
try the pomodoro technique
get yourself a kitchen timer some are
made to look like a pomodoro or tomato
and commit to working on a single task
as long as it's running
the pomodoro technique recommends 25
minutes of work and five minutes of rest
for each cycle
but you can also do 50 minutes of work
and 10 minutes of rest
find the pace that's best for you
the most important thing is to be
disciplined in completing each cycle
start your work session with a ritual
you enjoy and end it with a reward
train your mind to return to the present
when you find yourself getting
distracted
practice mindfulness or another form of
meditation go for a walk or a swim
whatever will help you get centered
again
work in a space where you will not be
distracted
if you can't do this at home go to a
library a cafe or if your task involves
playing the saxophone a music studio
if you find that your surroundings
continue to distract you keep looking
until you find the right place
divide each activity into groups of
related tasks and assign each group its
own place and time
for example if you're writing a magazine
article you could do research and take
notes at home in the morning
write in the library in the afternoon
and edit on the couch at night
bundle routine tasks such as sending out
invoices making phone calls and so on
and do them all at once
a summary of the advantages of flow
versus the disadvantages of distraction
a focused mind versus a wandering mind
living in the present versus thinking
about the past and the future
being free from worry versus having
concerns about our daily life and the
people around us invading our thoughts
having the hours fly by versus having
every minute seem endless
with flow we feel in control
with distraction we lose control and
fail to complete the task at hand or
other tasks or people keep us from our
work
with flow we prepare thoroughly with
distraction we act without being
prepared
with flow we know what we should be
doing at any given moment
when distracted we frequently get stuck
and don't know how to proceed
with flow our mind is clear and
overcomes all obstacles to the flow of
thought
with distraction we're plagued by doubts
concerns and low self-esteem
with flow it's pleasant
with distraction it's boring and
exhausting
and with flow
our ego fades we're not the ones
controlling the activity or task we're
doing the task is leading us
and with distraction
constant self-criticism
our ego is present and we feel
frustrated
flow in japan
takumi's engineers geniuses and otakus
what do takumi's artisans engineers
inventors and otakus fans of anime and
manga have in common
they all understand the importance of
flowing with their ikigai at all times
one widespread stereotype about people
in japan is that they're exceptionally
dedicated and hardworking even though
some japanese people say they look like
they're working harder than they really
are there is no doubt though about their
ability to be completely absorbed in a
task or about their perseverance when
there's a problem to be solved
one of the first words one learns when
starting japanese lessons is ganbaru
which means to persevere or to stay firm
by doing one's best
japanese people often apply themselves
to even the most basic tasks with an
intensity that borders on obsession
we see this in all kinds of contexts
from the retirees taking meticulous care
of their rice fields in the mountains of
nagano to the college students working
the weekend shift in convenience stores
known as konbinis
if you go to japan you'll experience
this attention to detail first hand in
almost every
walk into one of the stores that sell
handcrafted objects in naha kanazawa or
kyoto and you'll also discover that
japan is a treasure trove of traditional
craft work
the people of japan have a unique talent
for creating new technologies while
preserving artisanal traditions and
techniques
the art of the takumi
toyota employs artisans who are able to
make a certain type of screw by hand
these takumi or experts in a particular
manual skill are extremely important to
toyota and they're hard to replace
some of them are the only people who
know how to perform their exact skill
and it doesn't seem as though a new
generation is going to take up the
mantle
turntable needles are another example
they're produced almost exclusively in
japan where you can find the last
remaining people who know how to use the
machinery required to make these
precision needles and who are trying to
pass on their knowledge to their
descendants
we met at takumi on a visit to kumano a
small town near hiroshima
we were there for the day working on a
photo essay for one of the most famous
brands of makeup brushes in the west
the billboard welcoming visitors to
kamano shows a mascot holding a large
brush
in addition to the brush factories the
town is full of little houses and
vegetable gardens
heading farther in you can see several
shinto shrines at the base of the
mountains that surround the town
we spent hours taking photos in
factories full of people in orderly rows
each doing a single task such as
painting the handles of the brushes or
loading boxes of them onto trucks before
we realized we still hadn't seen anyone
actually putting bristles into the brush
heads
after we asked about this and got the
run around several times the president
of one company agreed to show us how it
was done
he led us out of the building and asked
us to get into his car
after a five five-minute drive we parked
next to another smaller structure and
climbed the stairs
he opened a door and we walked into a
small room filled with windows that led
in lovely natural light
in the middle of the room was a woman
wearing a mask
you could see only her eyes
she was so focused on choosing
individual bristles for the brushes
gracefully moving her hands and fingers
using scissors and cones to sort the
bristles that she didn't even notice our
presence
her movements were so quick it was hard
to tell what she was doing
the president of the company interrupted
her to let her know that we'd be taking
photos as she worked
we couldn't see her mouth but the glint
in her eye and the cheerful inflection
in her speech let us know she was
smiling
she looked happy and proud talking about
her work and responsibilities
we had to use extremely fast shutter
speeds to capture her movements
her hands danced and flowed in concert
with her tools and the bristles she was
sorting
the president told us that this takumi
was one of the most important people in
the company even though she was hidden
away in a separate building
every bristle of every brush the company
made passed through her hands
steve jobs in japan
apple co-founder steve jobs was a big
fan of japan
not only did he visit the sony factories
in the 1980s and adopt many of their
methods when he founded apple he was
also captivated by the simplicity and
quality of japanese porcelain in kyoto
it was not however an artisan from kyoto
who won steve jobs devotion but rather a
takomi from toyama named yokyo shakunaga
who used a technique called etchu
satoyaki known by only a few
on a visit to kyoto jobs heard of an
exhibition of shakunaga's work
he immediately understood that there was
something special about shakunaga's
porcelain
as a matter of fact he bought several
cups vases and plates and went back to
the show three times that week
jobs returned to kyoto several times
over the course of his life in search of
inspiration and ended up meeting
shakunaga in person
it is said that jobs had many questions
for him almost all of them about the
fabrication process and the type of
porcelain he used
shakunaga explained that he used white
porcelain he extracted himself from
mountains in the toyama prefecture
making him the only artist of his ilk
familiar with the fabrication process of
porcelain objects from their origins in
the mountains to their final form
an authentic takumi
jobs was so impressed that he considered
going to toyama to see the mountain
where shakunaga got his porcelain but
thought better of it when he heard that
it was more than four hours by train
from kyoto
in an interview after jobs death
shakunaga said he was very proud that
his work had been appreciated by the man
who created the iphone
he added that job's last purchase from
him had been a set of 12 teacups
jobs had asked for something special a
new style
to satisfy this request shakunaga made
150 teacups in the process of testing
out new ideas
of these
he chose the 12 best and sent them to
the jobs family
ever since his first trip to japan jobs
was fascinated and inspired by the
country's artisans
engineers especially at sony philosophy
especially zen and cuisine
especially sushi
sophisticated simplicity
what do japanese artisans engineers zen
philosophy and cuisine have in common
simplicity and attention to detail
it is not a lazy simplicity but a
sophisticated one that searches out new
frontiers
always taking the object the body and
mind or the cuisine to the next level
according to one ziki guy
as cheeks and mihai would say the key is
always having a meaningful challenge to
overcome in order to maintain flow
the documentary jiro dreams of sushi
gives us another example of a takumi
this time in the kitchen
its protagonist has been making sushi
every day for more than 80 years and
owns a small sushi restaurant near the
ginza subway station in tokyo
he and his son go every day to the
famous tsukiji fish market and choose
the best fish to bring back to the
restaurant
in the documentary we see one of jiro's
apprentices learning to make tamago a
thin slightly sweet omelet
no matter how hard he tries he can't get
jiro's approval
he keeps practicing for years until he
finally does
why does the apprentice refuse to give
up
doesn't he get bored cooking eggs every
day
no
because making sushi is his ikigai too
both jiro and his son are culinary
artists
they don't get bored when they cook they
achieve the state of flow
they enjoy themselves completely when
they're in the kitchen
that is their happiness their ikigai
they've learned to take pleasure in
their work to lose their sense of time
beyond the close relationship between
father and son which helps keep the
challenge going each day they also work
in a quiet peaceful environment that
allows them to concentrate
even after receiving a three-star rating
from michelin they never considered
opening other locations or expanding the
business
they serve just 10 patrons at a time at
the bar of their small restaurant
giro's family isn't looking to make
money
instead they value good working
conditions and creating an environment
in which they can flow while making the
best sushi in the world
jiro like yukio shakunaga begins his
work at the source
he goes to the fish market to find the
best tuna
naga goes to the mountains to find the
best porcelain
when they get down to work
both become one with the object they're
creating
this unity with the object that they
reach in a state of flow takes on
special meaning in japan where according
to shintoism forests trees and objects
have a kami
spirit or god within them
when someone whether an artist an
engineer or a chef sets out to create
something his or her responsibility is
to use nature to give it life while
respecting that nature at every moment
during this process the artisan becomes
one with the object and flows with it
an iron worker would say that metal has
a life of its own just as someone making
ceramics would say the clay does
the japanese are skilled at bringing
nature and technology together
not man versus nature but a union of the
two
the purity of ghibli
there are those who say that the shinto
value of being connected with nature is
vanishing
one of the harshest critics of this loss
is another artist with a clearly defined
ikigai
haiyo miyazaki the director of the
animated films produced by studio ghibli
in nearly all his films we see humans
technology fantasy and nature in a state
of conflict and in the end coming
together
one of the most poignant metaphors in
his film spirited away is an obese
spirit covered in trash that represents
pollution of the rivers
in miyazaki's films forests have
personalities trees have feelings and
robots befriend birds
considered a national treasure by the
japanese government miyazaki is an
artist capable of becoming completely
absorbed in his art
he uses a cell phone from the late 1990s
and he makes his entire team draw by
hand
he directs his films by rendering on
paper even the tiniest detail
achieving flow by drawing not by using a
computer
thanks to this obsession on the
director's part studio ghibli is one of
the only studios in the world where
almost the entire production process is
carried out using traditional techniques
those who have visited studio ghibli
know that it's fairly typical on a given
sunday to see a solitary individual
tucked away in a corner hard at work
a man in simple clothes who will greet
them with an ohio hello without looking
up
miyazaki is so passionate about his work
that he spends many sundays in the
studio enjoying the state of flow
putting his ikigai above all else
visitors know that under no
circumstances is one to bother miyazaki
who is known for his quick temper
especially if he is interrupted while
drawing
in 2013 miyazaki announced he was going
to retire
to commemorate his retirement the
television station nhk made a
documentary showing him in his last days
at work
he is drawing in nearly every scene of
the film
in one scene several of his colleagues
are seen coming out of a meeting and
there he is drawing in a corner paying
no attention to them
in another scene he is shown walking to
work on december 30th a national holiday
in japan and opening the doors of studio
ghibli so we can spend the day there
drawing alone
miyazaki can't stop drawing
the day after his retirement instead of
going on vacation or staying at home he
went to studio ghibli and sat down to
draw
his colleagues put on their best poker
faces not knowing what to say
one year later he announced he wouldn't
make any more feature films but that he
would keep on drawing until the day he
died
can someone really retire if he's
passionate about what he does
the recluses
it is not only the japanese who have
this capacity there are artists and
scientists all over the world with
strong clear icky guys
they do what they love until their dying
day
the last thing einstein wrote before
closing his eyes forever was a formula
that attempted to unite all the forces
of the universe in a single theory
when he died he was still doing what he
loved
if he hadn't been a physicist he said he
would have been happy as a musician when
he wasn't focused on physics or
mathematics he enjoyed playing the
violin
reaching a state of flow while working
on his formulas or playing music his two
icky guys brought him endless pleasure
many such artists might seem
misanthropic or reclusive
but what they are really doing is
protecting the time that brings them
happiness sometimes at the expense of
other aspects of their lives
they are outliers who apply the
principles of flow to their lives to an
extreme
another example of this kind of artist
is the novelist haruki murakami
he sees only a close circle of friends
and appears in public in japan only once
every few years
artists know how important it is to
protect their space control their
environment and be free from
distractions if they want to flow with
their icky guy
microflow
enjoying mundane tasks
what happens when we have to say do the
laundry mow the lawn or attend a
paperwork
is there a way to make these mundane
tasks enjoyable
near the shinjuku subway station in one
of the neural centers of tokyo there is
a supermarket that still employs
elevator operators the elevators are
fairly standard and could easily be
operated by the customers but the store
prefers to provide the service of
someone holding the door open for you
pushing the button for your floor and
bowing as you exit
if you ask around you'll learn that
there is one elevator operator who has
been doing the same job since 2004.
she is always smiling and enthusiastic
about her work
how is she able to enjoy such a job
doesn't she get bored doing something so
repetitive
on closer inspection it becomes clear
that the elevator operator is not just
pushing buttons
but is instead performing a whole
sequence of movements
she begins by greeting the customers
with a song-like salutation followed by
a bow and a welcoming wave of the hand
then she presses the elevator button
with a graceful movement as though she
is a geisha offering a client a cup of
tea
cheeks and mihai calls this microflow
we've all been bored in a class or at a
conference and started doodling to keep
ourselves entertained or whistled while
painting a wall
if we're not truly being challenged we
get bored and add a layer of complexity
to amuse ourselves
our ability to turn routine tasks into
moments of microflow into something we
enjoy
is key to our being happy since we all
have to do such tasks
even bill gates washes the dishes every
night he says he enjoys it that it helps
him relax and clear his mind and that he
tries to do it a little better each day
following an established order or set of
rules he's made for himself plates first
forks second and so on
it's one of his daily moments of
microflow
richard feynman one of the most
important physicists of all time also
took pleasure in routine tasks
w daniel hillis one of the founders of
the supercomputer manufacturer thinking
machines hired feynman to work on the
development of a computer that could
handle parallel processing when he was
already world famous
he says feynman showed up on his first
day of work and said okay boss what's my
assignment
they didn't have anything prepared so
they asked him to work on a certain
mathematical problem
he immediately realized they were giving
him an irrelevant task to keep him busy
and said that sounds like a bunch of
baloney give me something real to do
so they sent him to a nearby shop to buy
office supplies and he completed his
assignment with a smile on his face
when he didn't have something important
to do or needed to rest his mind feynman
dedicated himself to microflowing say
painting the office walls
weeks later after visiting the thinking
machines offices a group of investors
declared you have a nobel laureate in
there painting walls and soldering
circuits
instant vacations
getting there through meditation
training the mind can get us to a place
of flow more quickly
meditation is one way to exercise our
mental muscles
there are many types of meditation but
they all have the same objective calming
the mind
observing our thoughts and emotions and
centering our focus on a single object
the basic practice involves sitting with
a straight back and focusing on your
breath
anyone can do it and you feel a
difference after just one session
by fixing your attention on the air
moving in and out of your nose you can
slow the torrent of thoughts and clear
your mental horizons
the archer's secret
the winner of the 1988 olympic gold
medal for archery was a 17 year old
woman from south korea
when asked how she prepared she replied
that the most important part of her
training was meditating for two hours
each day
if we want to get better at reaching a
state of flow meditation is an excellent
antidote to our smartphones and their
notifications constantly clamoring for
our attention
one of the most common mistakes among
people starting to meditate is worrying
about doing it right
achieving absolute mental silence or
reaching nirvana
the most important thing
is to focus on the journey
since the mind is a constant swirl of
thoughts ideas and emotions slowing down
the centrifuge even for just a few
seconds can help us feel more rested and
leave us with a sense of clarity
in fact one of the things we learn in
the practice of meditation is not to
worry about anything that flits across
our mental screen
the idea of killing our boss might flash
into our mind but we simply label it as
a thought and let it pass like a cloud
without judging or rejecting it
it's only a thought
one of the sixty thousand we have every
day according to some experts
meditation generates alpha and theta
brain waves
for those experienced in meditation
these waves appear right away while it
might take half an hour for a beginner
to experience them
these relaxing brain waves are the ones
that are activated right before we fall
asleep
as we lie in the sun or right after
taking a hot bath
we all carry a spa with us everywhere we
go
it's just a matter of knowing how to get
in
something anyone can do with a bit of
practice
humans as ritualistic beings
life is inherently ritualistic
we could argue that humans naturally
follow rituals that keep us busy
in some modern cultures we've been
forced out of our ritualistic lives to
pursue goal after goal in order to be
seen as successful
but throughout history humans have
always been busy
we were hunting cooking farming
exploring and raising families
activities that were structured as
rituals to keep us busy throughout our
days
but in an unusual way rituals still
permeate daily life and business
practices in modern japan
the main religions in japan confucianism
buddhism and shintoism are all ones in
which the rituals are more important
than absolute rules
when doing business in japan process
manners and how you work on something is
more important than the final results
whether this is good or bad for the
economy is beyond the scope of this
audio book
what is indisputable though is that
finding flow in a ritualistic workplace
is much easier than in one in which we
are continually stressed out trying to
achieve unclear goals set by our bosses
rituals give us clear rules and
objectives which help us enter a state
of flow
when we have only a big goal in front of
us we might feel lost or overwhelmed by
it
rituals help us by giving us the process
the sub steps on the path to achieving a
goal
when confronted with a big goal try to
break it down into parts and then attack
each part one by one
focus on enjoying your daily rituals
using them as tools to enter a state of
flow
don't worry about the outcome it will
come naturally
happiness is in the doing
not in the result
as a rule of thumb remind yourself
rituals over goals
the happiest people are not the ones who
achieve the most they're the ones who
spend more time than others in a state
of flow
using flow to find your ikigai
after hearing this chapter you should
have a better idea of which activities
in your life make you enter flow
write all of them on a piece of paper
then ask yourself three questions
what do the activities that drive you to
flow have in common
why do these activities drive you to
flow
for example are all the activities you
most like doing ones that you practice
alone or with other people
do you flow more when doing things that
require you to move your body or just to
think
in the answers to these questions you
might find the underlying icky guy that
drives your life
if you don't then keep searching by
going deeper into what you like by
spending more of your time in the
activities that make you flow
also try new things that are not on the
list of what makes you flow but that are
similar and that you're curious about
for example if photography is something
that drives you into flow you could also
try painting
you might even like it more
or if you love snowboarding and have
never tried surfing flow is mysterious
it's like a muscle
the more you train it the more you will
flow
and the closer you'll be to your icky
guy
chapter 5
masters of longevity
words of wisdom from the longest living
people in the world
when we started working on this
audiobook we didn't want to just
research the factors that contribute to
a long and happy life we wanted to hear
from the true masters of this art
the interviews we conducted in okinawa
merit their own chapter but in the
section that precedes it we've provided
an overview of the life philosophies of
a few international champions of
longevity
we're talking about super centenarians
people who live to 110 years of age or
more
the term was coined in 1970 by norris
mcwhorter editor of the guinness book of
world records
its use became more widespread in the
1990s after it appeared in william
strauss and neil howe's generations
today there are an estimated 300 to 450
super centenarians in the world although
the age of only around 75 of them has
been confirmed
they aren't superheroes but we could see
them as such for having spent far more
time on this planet than the average
life expectancy would predict
given the rise in life expectancy around
the world the number of super
centenarians might also increase
a healthy and purposeful life could help
us join their ranks
let's take a look at what a few of them
have to say
misao okawa
117.
eat and sleep and you'll live a long
time
you have to learn to relax
according to the gerontology research
group until april 2015 the oldest living
person in the world was misawa okawa who
passed away in a care facility in osaka
japan after living for 117 years 27 days
the daughter of a textile merchant she
was born in 1898 when spain lost its
colonies in cuba and the philippines
and the united states annexed hawaii and
launched pepsicola
until she was 110 this woman who lived
in three different centuries cared for
herself unassisted
when specialists asked about her
self-care routine misawa answered simply
eating sushi and sleeping
to which we should add having a
tremendous thirst for life
when they inquired about her secret for
longevity she answered with a smile
i asked myself the same thing
proof that japan continues to be a
factory of long life
in july of the same year sakari momoy
passed away at 112 years and 150 days
old
at the time he was the oldest man in the
world though he was younger than 57
women
maria capovia
116.
i've never eaten meat in my life
born in ecuador in 1889 maria capovia
was recognized by guinness as the
world's oldest person
she died of pneumonia in 2006 at 116
years and 347 days old
leaving behind three children
12 grandchildren and 20 great and
great-great-grandchildren
she gave one of her last interviews at
age 107 sharing her memories and her
thoughts
i'm happy and i give thanks to god who
keeps me going
i never thought i'd live so long i
thought i'd die long ago
my husband antonio capovia was the
captain of a ship he passed away at 84.
we had two daughters and a son and now i
have many grandchildren and
great-grandchildren
things were better back in the old days
people behaved better
we used to dance but we were more
restrained there was this one song i
love dancing to maria by luis halacon
i still remember most of the words
i also remember many prayers and say
them every day
i like the waltz
and can still dance it
i also still make crafts i do some of
the things i did when i was in school
when she had finished recalling her past
she began to dance one of her great
passions with an energy that made her
seem decades younger
when asked about her secret for
longevity she responded simply i don't
know what the secret to long life is the
only thing i do is i've never eaten meat
in my life i attribute it to that
jean calm on
122.
everything's fine
born in aurel france in february 1875
jean calment lived until august 4th 1997
making her at 122 the oldest person of
verified age in history
she jokingly said that she competed with
methuselah and there is no question that
she broke numerous records as she went
on celebrating birthdays
she died of natural causes at the end of
a happy life during which she denied
herself almost nothing
she rode a bicycle until she turned a
hundred she lived on her own until 110
when she agreed to move into a nursing
home after accidentally starting a small
fire in her apartment
she stopped smoking at 120 when her
cataracts started making it hard for her
to bring a cigarette to her lips
one of her secrets may have been her
sense of humor
as she said on her 120th birthday
i see badly i hear badly and i feel bad
but
everything's fine
walter bruning 114
if you keep your mind and body busy
you'll be around a long time
born in minnesota in 1896 walter bruning
was able to see three centuries in his
lifetime
he died in montana in 2011 from natural
causes
he'd had two wives and a 50-year career
on the railroad
at 83 he retired to an assisted living
center in montana where he remained
until his death
he is the second oldest man a verified
age ever born in the united states
he gave many interviews in his final
years insisting that his longevity
stemmed from among other things his
habit of eating only two meals per day
and working for as many hours as he
could
your mind and your body you keep both
busy he said on his 112th birthday
you'll be here a long time
back then he was still exercising every
day
among bruning's other secrets
he had a habit of helping others and he
wasn't afraid of dying as he declared in
a 2010 interview with the associated
press
we're all going to die
some people are scared of dying
never be afraid to die because you're
born to die
before passing away in 2011 he is said
to have told a pastor that he'd made a
deal with god
if he wasn't going to get better
it was time to go
alexander emich 111
i just haven't died yet
born in poland in 1903 alexander emich
was a chemist and parapsychologist
residing in the united states who after
the death of his predecessor in 2014
became the oldest man of authenticated
age in the world
emmett himself died a year thereafter in
june of that year
leaving behind a long life rich with
experiences
emmett attributed his longevity to among
other things
never drinking alcohol
it's not as though i'd won the nobel
prize
he said upon being declared the world's
oldest man i never thought i'd get to be
so old
when asked about his secret to living so
long his answer was
i don't know
i just haven't died yet
icky guy artists
the secret to long life however is not
held by super centenarians alone
there are many people of advanced age
who though they haven't made it into
guinness world records offer us
inspiration and ideas for bringing
energy and meaning to our lives
artists for example who carry the torch
of their ikigai instead of retiring have
this power
art in all its forms is an ikigai that
can bring happiness and purpose to our
days
enjoying or creating beauty is free and
something all human beings have access
to
hokusai the japanese artist who made
wood block prints in the ukiyoa style
and lived for 88 years from the mid-18th
to the mid-19th century added this
postscript to the first edition of his
100 views of mount fuji
all that i have produced before the age
of 70 is not worth being counted
it is at the age of 73 that i have
somewhat begun to understand the
structure of true nature
of animals and grasses and trees and
birds and fishes and insects
consequently at 80 years of age i shall
have made still more progress
at 90 i hope to have penetrated into the
mystery of things
at 100 years of age i should have
reached decidedly a marvelous degree
and when i shall be 110 all that i do
every point and every line shall be
instinct with life
following is our collection of some of
the most inspirational words from
artists interviewed by camille sweeney
for the new york times
of those still living none have retired
and all still enjoy their passion which
they plan to pursue until their final
breath demonstrating that when you have
a clear purpose no one can stop you
the actor christopher plummer still
working at 86 reveals a dark desire
shared by many who love the profession
we want to drop dead on stage
that would be a nice theatrical way to
go
osama tazuka the father of modern
japanese manga shared this feeling
before he died in 1989 his last words as
he drew one final cartoon were please
just let me work
the 86 year old filmmaker frederick
wiseman declared on a stroll through
paris that he likes to work which is why
he does it with such intensity
everybody complains about the rakes and
pains and all that but my friends are
either dead or are still working
he said
carmen herrera a painter who just
entered her 100th year sold her first
canvas at 89.
today her work is in the permanent
collections of the tate modern and the
museum of modern art
when asked how she viewed her future she
responded
i'm always waiting to finish the next
thing
absurd i know
i go day by day
never stop learning
you may grow old and trembling in your
anatomies
you may lie awake at night listening to
the disorder of your veins
you may miss your only love
you may see the world about you
devastated by evil lunatics or know your
honor trampled in the sewers of baser
mines
there is only one thing for it then to
learn
learn why the world wags and what wags
it
that is the only thing which the mind
can never exhaust
never alienate never be tortured by
never fear or distrust and never dream
of regretting
t.h white
the once and future king
for his part naturalist and author
edward o wilson asserted i feel i have
enough experience to join those who are
addressing big questions
about 10 years ago when i began reading
and thinking more broadly about the
questions of what are we where did we
come from and where are we going i was
astonished at how little this was being
done
ellsworth kelly an artist who passed
away in 2015 at the age of 92 assured us
that the idea that we lose our faculties
with age is in part a myth because
instead we develop a greater clarity and
capacity for observation
it's one thing about getting older you
see more
every day i'm continuing to see new
things
that's why there are new paintings
at age 86 the architect frank gehry
reminds us that some buildings can take
seven years from the time you're hired
until you're finished
a fact that favors a patient attitude
with regard to the passage of time
the man responsible for the guggenheim
museum bilbao however knows how to live
in the here and now
you stay in your time you don't go
backward
i think if you relate to the time you're
in you keep your eyes and ears open read
the paper see what's going on stay
curious about everything you will
automatically be in your time
longevity in japan
because of its robust civil registry
many of those verified as having lived
the longest are found in the united
states
however there are many centenarians
living in remote villages in other
countries
a peaceful life in the countryside seems
pretty common among people who have
watched a century pass
without question the international
superstar of longevity is japan which
has the highest life expectancy of any
country in the world
in addition to a healthy diet which we
will explore in detail and an integrated
health care system in which people go to
the doctor for regular checkups to
prevent disease
longevity in japan is closely tied to
its culture as we'll see later on
the sense of community and the fact that
japanese people make an effort to stay
active until the very end are key
elements of their secret to long life
if you want to stay busy even when
there's no need to work there has to be
an ikigai on your horizon
a purpose that guides you throughout
your life and pushes you to make things
of beauty and utility for the community
and yourself
chapter six
lessons from japan's centenarians
traditions and proverbs for happiness
and longevity
to get to ogini we had to fly nearly
three hours from tokyo to naha the
capital of okinawa
several months earlier we'd contacted
the town council of a place known as the
village of longevity to explain the
purpose of our trip and our intention to
interview the oldest members of the
community
after numerous conversations we finally
got the help we were looking for and
were able to rent a house just outside
the town
one year after starting this project we
found ourselves on the doorstep of some
of the longest living people in the
world
we realized right away that time seems
to have stopped there as though the
entire town were living in an endless
here and now
arriving in ogimi
after two hours on the road from naha
we're finally able to stop worrying
about the traffic
to our left are the sea and an empty
stretch of beach to our right the
mountainous jungle of okinawa's yanbaru
forests
once route 58 passes nago where orion
beer the pride of okinawa is made it
skirts the coast until it reaches ogimi
every now and then a few little houses
and stores crop up in the narrow stretch
of land between the road and the base of
the mountain
we pass small clusters of houses
scattered here and there as we enter the
municipality of oguimi but the town
doesn't really seem to have a center
our gps finally guides us to our
destination
the center for the support and promotion
of well-being
housed in an unattractive cinderblock
building right off the highway
we go in through the back door where a
man named tyra is waiting for us
beside him is a petite cheerful woman
who introduces herself as yuki
two other women immediately get up from
desks and show us to a conference room
they serve us each a cup of green tea
and a few shikawasa a small citrus fruit
that packs a big nutritional punch as
we'll see later on
taira sits down across from us in his
formal suit and opens up a large planner
and a three-ring binder yuki sits next
to him the binder contains a list of all
the town's residents organized by age
and club or moai
taira points out that these groups of
people who help one another are
characteristic of ogimi
the moai are not organized around any
concrete objective they function more
like a family
taira also tells us that volunteer work
rather than money drives much of what
happens in ogimi
everyone offers to pitch in and the
local government takes care of assigning
tasks this way everyone can be useful
and feels like part of the community
ogimi is the penultimate town before
cape hedo the northernmost point of the
largest island in the archipelago
from the top of ogimi's mountains we're
able to look down over the whole town
almost everything is the green of the
yanbaru jungle making us wonder where
the nearly 3200 residents are hiding
we can see a few houses but they're
scattered in little clusters near the
sea or in small valleys accessible by
side roads
communal life
we're invited to eat in one of ogimi's
few restaurants but when we arrive the
only three tables are already reserved
don't worry we'll go to churaumi instead
it never fills up
says yuki walking back to the car
she's still driving at age 88 and takes
great pride in that
her co-pilot is 99 and has also decided
to spend the day with us
we have to drive fast to keep up with
them on a highway that is sometimes more
dirt than asphalt
finally reaching the other end of the
jungle we can at last sit down to eat
i don't really go to restaurants yuki
says as we take our seats almost
everything i eat comes from my vegetable
garden and i buy my fish from tanaka
who's been my friend forever
the restaurant is right by the sea and
seems like something from the planet
tatooine from star wars
the menu boasts in large letters that it
serves slow food prepared with organic
vegetables grown in the town
but really yuki continues food is the
least important thing
she is extroverted and rather pretty
she likes to talk about her role as the
director of several associations run by
the local government
food won't help you live longer she says
bringing to her lips a bite of the
diminutive confection that followed our
meal
the secret is smiling and having a good
time
there are no bars and only a few
restaurants in ogimi but those who live
there enjoy a rich social life that
revolves around community centers
the town is divided into 17
neighborhoods and each one has a
president and several people in charge
of things like culture festivals social
activities and longevity
residents pay close attention to this
last category
we're invited to the community center of
one of the 17 neighborhoods
it's an old building right next to one
of the mountains of the yanburu jungle
home to bunagaya the town's iconic
sprites
the bonagaya spirits of the yanbaru
jungle
bunigaya are magical creatures that
inhabit the yanbaru jungle near ogimi
and its surrounding towns
they manifest as children with long red
hair
and like to hide in the jungle's
kajumaru banyan trees and go fishing on
the beach
many of okinawa's stories and fables are
about bona gaya sprites
they're mischievous playful and
unpredictable
locals say that the bunnagaya love the
mountains rivers sea trees earth wind
and animals and that if you want to
befriend them you have to show respect
for nature
a birthday party
when we arrive at the neighborhoods
community center we're greeted by a
group of about 20 people who proudly
proclaim
the youngest among us is 83.
we conduct our interviews at a large
table while drinking green tea
when we finish we're brought to an event
space where we celebrate the birthdays
of three members of the group
one woman is turning 99 another 94 and
one young man has just reached 89.
we sing a few songs popular in the
village and finish up with happy
birthday in english
the woman turning 99 blows out the
candles and thanks everyone for coming
to her party
we eat homemade shikawasa cake and end
up dancing and celebrating as though it
were the birthday of a 20-something
it's the first party but not the last
that we'll attend during our week in the
village
we'll also do karaoke with a group of
seniors who sing better than we do and
attend a traditional festival with local
bands dancers and food stands at the
foot of a mountain
celebrate each day
together
celebrations seem to be an essential
part of life in ogimi
we're invited to watch a game of gate
ball one of the most popular sports
among okinawa's older residents
it involves hitting a ball with a
mallet-like stick
it's a low-impact sport that can be
played anywhere and it's a good excuse
to move around and have fun as a group
the residents hold local competitions
and there is no age limit for
participants
we participate in the weekly game and
lose to a woman who recently turned 104
everyone cheers and the defeated look on
our faces elicits laughter
in addition to playing and celebrating
as a community
spirituality is also essential to the
happiness of the village's residence
the gods of okie
the main religion in okinawa is known as
ryukyu shinto
ryukyu is the original name of the
okinawa archipelago and shinto means the
path of the gods
ryukyu shinto combines elements of
chinese taoism confucianism buddhism and
shintoism with shamanistic and animistic
elements
according to this ancient faith the
world is populated by an infinite number
of spirits divided into several types
spirits of the home of the forest of the
trees and of the mountains
it's important to appease these spirits
through rituals and festivals and by
consecrating sacred grounds
okinawa is full of sacred jungles and
forests where many of the two main kinds
of temples are found
the uttaki and the uganju
we visited an ugandu or small open air
temple adorned with incense and coins
next to a waterfall in ogimi
the uttaki is a collection of stones
where people go to pray and where
supposedly spirits gather
in okinawa's religious practice women
are considered spiritually superior to
men whereas the opposite is true of
traditional shintoism in the rest of
japan
utah
are women chosen as mediums by their
communities to make contact with the
spirit realm through traditional rights
ancestor worship is another important
feature of spiritual practice in okinawa
and in japan in general the home of each
generation's firstborn usually contains
a buttsudan or small altar used to pray
for and make offerings to the family's
ancestors
mabui
every person has an essence or mabui
this mabui is our spirit and the source
of our life force
it is immortal and makes us who we are
sometimes the mabui of someone who has
died is trapped in the body of a living
person
this situation requires a separation
ritual to free them a buoy of the
deceased
it often happens when a person dies
suddenly especially at a young age and
his or her mobui does not want to move
on to the realm of the dead
hamabui can also be passed from person
to person by physical contact
a grandmother who leaves her
granddaughter a ring transfers a part of
her mabui to her
photographs can also be a medium for
passing mabui among people
the older the stronger
looking back our days in ogimi were
intense but relaxed
sort of like the lifestyle of the locals
who always seem to be busy with
important tasks but who upon closer
inspection did everything with a sense
of calm
they were always pursuing their icky guy
but they were never in a rush
not only did they seem to be happily
busy but we also noticed that they
followed the other principles for
happiness that washington bernab stated
200 years ago
the grand essentials to happiness in
this life are something to do
something to love
and something to hope for
on our last day we went to buy gifts at
a small market at the edge of town
the only thing sold there are local
vegetables green tea and shikawasa juice
along with bottles of water from a
spring hidden in the yamburu forests
bearing labels that read longevity water
we bought ourselves some of this
longevity water and drank it in the
parking lot looking out over the sea and
hoping that the little bottles that
promised a magic elixir would bring us
health and long life and would help us
find our own icky guy
then we took a photo with a statue of
abu nagaya and walked up to it one last
time to read the inscription
a declaration from the town where people
live longest
at 80 i am still a child
when i come to see you at 90 send me a
way to wait until i am a hundred
the older the stronger
let us not depend too much on our
children as we age if you seek long life
and health you are welcome in our
village where you will be blessed by
nature and together we will discover the
secret to longevity
april 23 1993 oguimi federation of
senior citizens clubs
the interviews
over the course of a week we conducted a
total of 100 interviews asking the
eldest members of the community about
their life philosophy their ikigai and
the secrets to longevity
we filmed these conversations with two
cameras for use in a little documentary
and shows a few especially meaningful
and inspiring statements to include in
this section of the audiobook
one
don't worry
the secret to a long life is not to
worry and to keep your heart young don't
let it grow old
open your heart to people with a nice
smile on your face
if you smile and open your heart your
grandchildren and everyone else will
want to see you
the best way to avoid anxiety is to go
out in the street and say hello to
people
i do it every day
i go out there and say hello and see you
later
then i go home and care for my vegetable
garden
in the afternoon i spend time with
friends
here everyone gets along
we try not to cause problems
spending time together and having fun is
the only thing that matters
two
cultivate good habits
i feel joy every morning waking up at
six and opening the curtains to look out
at my garden where i grow my own
vegetables
i go right outside to check on my
tomatoes my mandarin oranges
i love the sight of them it relaxes me
after an hour in the garden i go back
inside and make breakfast
i plant my own vegetables and cook them
myself that's my ikigai
the key to staying sharp in old age is
in your fingers from your fingers to
your brain and back again
if you keep your fingers busy you'll
live to see one hundred
i get up at four every day i set my
alarm for that time have a cup of coffee
and do a little exercise lifting my arms
that gives me energy for the rest of the
day
i eat a bit of everything i think that's
the secret i like variety in what i eat
i think it tastes better
working if you don't work your body
breaks down
when i wake up i go to the butt sedan
and light incense you have to keep your
ancestors in mind it's the first thing i
do every morning
i wake up every day at the same time
early and spend the morning in my
vegetable garden
i go dancing with my friends once a week
i do exercise every day and every
morning i go for a little walk
i never forget to do my taiso exercises
when i get up
eating vegetables it helps you live
longer
to live a long time you need to do three
things
exercise to stay healthy
eat well
and spend time with people
three
nurture your friendships every day
getting together with my friends is my
most important ikigai
we all get together here and talk it's
very important
i always know i'll see them all here
tomorrow and that's one of my favorite
things in life
my main hobby is getting together with
friends and neighbors
talking each day with the people you
love
that's the secret to a long life
i say hello and see you later to the
children on their way to school and wave
at everyone who goes by me in their car
drive safely i say
between 7 20 a.m and 8 15 a.m i'm
outside on my feet the whole time saying
hello to people
once everyone's gone i go back inside
chatting and drinking tea with my
neighbors that's the best thing in life
and singing together
i wake up at five every morning leave
the house and walk to the sea
then i go to a friend's house and we
have tea together
that's the secret to a long life
getting together with people and going
from place to place
four
live an unhurried life
secret to a long life is always saying
to myself
slow down and relax
you live much longer if you're not in a
hurry
i make things with wicker that's my icky
guy
the first thing i do when i wake up is
pray
then i do my exercises and eat breakfast
at seven i calmly start working on my
wicker
when i get tired at five i go visit my
friends
doing many different things every day
always staying busy but doing one thing
at a time without getting overwhelmed
the secret to long life is going to bed
early waking up early and going for a
walk
living peacefully and enjoying the
little things getting along with your
friends spring summer fall winter
enjoying each season happily
five
be optimistic
every day i say to myself today will be
full of health and energy
live it to the fullest
i'm 98 but consider myself young i still
have so much to do
laugh
laughter is the most important thing
i laugh wherever i go
i'm going to live to be a hundred of
course i am it's a huge motivation for
me
dancing and singing with your
grandchildren is the best thing in life
i feel very fortunate to have been born
here i give thanks for it every day
the most important thing in ogimi in
life is to keep smiling
i do volunteer work to give back to the
village a bit of what it is given to me
for example i use my car to help friends
get to the hospital
there's no secret to it the trick is
just to live
keys to the ogimi lifestyle
one hundred percent of the people we
interviewed keep a vegetable garden and
most of them also have fields of tea
mangoes shikawasa and so on
all belong to some form of neighborhood
association where they feel cared for as
though by family
they celebrate all the time even little
things
music song and dance are essential parts
of daily life
they have an important purpose in life
or several
they have an achy guy but they don't
take it too seriously
they're relaxed and enjoy all that they
do
they are very proud of their traditions
and local culture
they are passionate about everything
they do however insignificant it might
seem
locals have a strong sense of yui ma'aru
recognizing the connection between
people
they help each other with everything
from work in the fields harvesting
sugarcane or planting rice to building
houses and municipal projects
our friend miyagi who ate dinner with us
on our last night in town told us that
he was building a new home with the help
of all his friends and that we could
stay there the next time we were in
ogimi
they are always busy but they occupy
themselves with tasks that allow them to
relax
we didn't see a single old grandpa
sitting on a bench doing nothing
they're always coming and going to sing
karaoke visit with neighbors or play a
game of gate ball
chapter 7
the ikigai diet
what the world's longest living people
eat and drink
according to the world health
organization japan has the highest life
expectancy in the world 85 years for men
and 87.3 years for women
moreover it has the highest ratio of
centenarians in the world
more than 520 for every million people
as of september 2016.
while life expectancy in japan is high
overall okinawa exceeds the national
average
okinawa is one of the areas in japan
that were most affected by world war ii
as a result not only of conflicts on the
battlefield
but also of hunger and a lack of
resources once the war ended the average
life expectancy was not very high during
the 1940s and 1950s
as okinawans recovered from the
destruction however they came to be some
of the country's longest living citizens
what secrets to long life to the
japanese hold
what is it about okinawa that makes it
the best of the best in terms of life
expectancy
experts point out that for one thing
okinawa is the only province in japan
without trains
its residents have to walk or cycle when
not driving
it's also the only province that has
managed to follow the japanese
government's recommendation of eating
less than 10 grams of salt per day
okinawa's miracle diet
the mortality rate from cardiovascular
disease in okinawa is the lowest in
japan
and diet almost certainly has a lot to
do with this
it's no coincidence that the okinawa
diet is so often discussed around the
world at panels on nutrition
the most concrete and widely cited data
on diet in okinawa came from studies by
makoto suzuki a cardiologist at the
university of ryukus who has published
more than 700 scientific articles on
nutrition and aging in okinawa since
1970
bradley j wilcox and d craig wilcox
joined makoto suzuki's research team and
published a book considered the bible on
the subject the okinawa program
they reached the following conclusions
locals eat a wide variety of foods
especially vegetables
variety seems to be key
a study of okinawa's centenarians showed
that they ate 206 different foods
including spices on a regular basis
they ate an average of 18 different
foods each day
a striking contrast to the nutritional
poverty of our fast food culture
they eat at least five servings of
fruits and vegetables every day
at least seven types of fruits and
vegetables are consumed by okinawans on
a daily basis
the easiest way to check if there's
enough variety on your table is to make
sure you're eating the rainbow
a table featuring red peppers carrots
spinach cauliflower and eggplant for
example offers great color and variety
vegetables potatoes legumes and soy
products such as tofu are the staples of
an okinawan's diet
more than 30 percent of their daily
calories come from vegetables
grains are the foundation of their diet
japanese people eat white rice every day
sometimes adding noodles
rice is the primary food in okinawa as
well
they rarely eat sugar
and if they do it's cane sugar
we drove through several sugarcane
fields every morning on our way to ogimi
and even drank a glass of cane juice at
nakijin castle
beside the stall selling the juice was a
sign describing the anti-carcinogenic
benefits of sugar cane
in addition to these basic dietary
principles okinawans eat fish an average
of three times per week unlike in other
parts of japan the most frequently
consumed meat is pork though locals eat
it only once or twice per week
along these lines makoto suzuki studies
indicate the following
okinawans consume in general one-third
as much sugar as the rest of japan's
population which means that sweets and
chocolate are much less a part of their
diet
they also eat practically half as much
salt as the rest of japan
seven grams per day compared to an
average of 12.
they consume fewer calories an average
of
1785 per day compared to 2068 in the
rest of japan
in fact
low caloric intake is common among the
five blue zones
harahachibu
this brings us back to the 80 rule we
mentioned in the first chapter a concept
known in japanese as harahachibu
it's easy to do
when you notice you're almost full but
could have a little more just stop
eating
one easy way to start applying the
concept of harahachi buu is to skip
dessert or to reduce portion size
the idea is to still be a little bit
hungry when you finish
this is why portion size tends to be
much smaller in japan than in the west
food isn't served as appetizers main
courses and dessert
instead it's much more common to see
everything presented at once on small
plates
one with rice another with vegetables a
bowl of miso soup and something to snack
on
serving food on many small plates makes
it easier to avoid eating too much and
facilitates the varied diet discussed at
the beginning of this chapter
haruhachibu is an ancient practice
the 12th century book on zen buddhism
zazen yo jinki recommends eating two
thirds as much as you might want to
eating less than one might want is
common among all buddhist temples in the
east
perhaps buddhism recognized the benefits
of limiting caloric intake more than
nine centuries ago
so
eat less to live longer
few would challenge this idea
without taking it to the extreme of
malnutrition of course eating fewer
calories than our bodies ask for seems
to increase longevity
the key to staying healthy while
consuming fewer calories is eating foods
with a high nutritional value especially
superfoods and avoiding those that add
to our overall caloric intake but offer
little to no nutritional value
the calorie restriction we've been
discussing is one of the most effective
ways to add years to your life
if the body regularly consumes enough or
too many calories it gets lethargic and
starts to wear down expending
significant energy on digestion alone
another benefit of calorie restriction
is that it reduces levels of igf-1
insulin-like growth factor one in the
body
igf-1 is a protein that plays a
significant role in the aging process
it seems that one of the reasons humans
and animals age is an excess of this
protein in their blood
whether calorie restriction will extend
lifespan in humans is not yet known but
data increasingly indicate that moderate
calorie restriction with adequate
nutrition has a powerful protective
effect against obesity type 2 diabetes
inflammation hypertension and
cardiovascular disease and reduces
metabolic risk factors associated with
cancer
an alternative to following the eighty
percent rule on a daily basis is to fast
for one or two days each week
the 5-2 or fasting diet recommends two
days of fasting consuming fewer than 500
calories every week and eating normally
on the other five days
among its many benefits fasting helps
cleanse the digestive system and allows
it to rest
15 natural antioxidants found in the
okinawan diet
antioxidants are molecules that slow
down the oxidation process in cells
neutralizing the free radicals that
cause damage and accelerate aging
the antioxidant power of green tea for
example is well known and will be
discussed later at greater length
because they are rich in antioxidants
and are eaten nearly every day in the
region these 15 foods are considered
keys to okinawan vitality
tofu
miso
tuna
carrots
goya a bitter melon
kombu sea kelp
cabbage
nori
seaweed onion
soy sprouts
hechima a cucumber like gourd
soy beans boiled or raw sweet potato
peppers and san pincha jasmine tea
senpincha
the reigning infusion in okinawa
okinawans drink more san pincha a mix of
green tea and jasmine flowers than any
other kind of tea
the closest approximation in the west
would be the jasmine tea that usually
comes from china
a 1988 study conducted by hiroko show at
the okinawa institute of science and
technology indicates that jasmine tea
reduces blood cholesterol levels
sam pincha can be found in many
different forms in okinawa and is even
available in vending machines
in addition to all the antioxidant
benefits of green tea it boasts the
benefits of jasmine which include
reducing the risk of heart attack
strengthening the immune system
helping relieve stress
lowering cholesterol
okinawans drink an average of three cups
of san pincha every day
it might be hard to find exactly the
same blend in the west but we can drink
jasmine tea or even a high quality green
tea instead
the secrets of green tea
green tea has been credited for
centuries with significant medicinal
properties
recent studies have confirmed its many
benefits and have attested to the
importance of this ancient plant in the
longevity of those who drink it often
originally from china where it's been
consumed for millennia green tea didn't
make its way to the rest of the world
until just a few centuries ago
unlike other teas and as a result of
being air dried without fermentation it
retains its active elements even after
being dried and crumbled
it offers meaningful health benefits
such as
controlling cholesterol
lowering blood sugar levels
improving circulation
protection against the flu vitamin c
promoting bone health fluoride
protection against certain bacterial
infections protection against uv damage
cleansing and diuretic effects
white tea with its high concentration of
polyphenols may be even more effective
against aging
in fact it's considered to be the
natural product with the greatest
antioxidant power in the world to the
extent that one cup of white tea might
pack the same punch as a dozen glasses
of orange juice
in summary drinking green or white tea
every day can help us reduce the free
radicals in our bodies keeping us young
longer
the powerful shikawasa
shikawasa is the citrus fruit par
excellence of okinawa and ogimi is its
largest producer in all of japan
the fruit is extremely acidic it's
impossible to drink shikawasa juice
without diluting it first with water
its taste is somewhere between that of a
lime and a mandarin orange to which it
bears a family resemblance shikawasas
also contain high levels of nobilityn a
flavonoid rich in antioxidants
all citrus fruits grapefruits oranges
lemons are high in no bulletin but
okinawa's shikawasas have 40 times as
much as oranges
consuming no bulletin has been proven to
protect us from arteriosclerosis
cancer type 2 diabetes and obesity in
general
shikawasas also contain vitamins c and b
beta carotene and minerals
they're used in many traditional dishes
and to add flavor to food and are
squeezed to make juice
while conducting research at the
birthday parties of the town's
grandparents we were served shikawasa
cake
antioxidant cannon for westerners
in 2010 the uk's daily mirror published
a list of foods recommended by experts
to combat aging
among these foods readily available in
the west are
vegetables such as broccoli and chard
for their high concentration of water
minerals and fiber
oily fish such as salmon mackerel tuna
and sardines for all the antioxidants in
their fat
fruits such as citrus strawberries and
apricots
they're an excellent source of vitamins
and help eliminate toxins from the body
berries such as blueberries and goji
berries they're rich in phytochemical
antioxidants
dried fruits which contain vitamins and
antioxidants and give you energy
grains such as oats and wheat which give
you energy and contain minerals
olive oil for its antioxidant effects
that show in your skin
red wine in moderation for its
antioxidant and vasodilatory properties
foods that should be eliminated are
refined sugar and grains
processed baked goods and prepared foods
along with cow's milk and all its
derivatives
following this diet will help you feel
younger and slow the process of
premature aging
chapter 8
gentle movements longer life
exercises from the east that promote
health and longevity
studies from the blue zone suggest that
the people who live the longest are not
the ones who do the most exercise but
rather the ones who move the most
when we visited oguimi the village of
longevity we discovered that even people
over 80 and 90 years old are still
highly active
they don't stay at home looking out the
window or reading the newspaper
ogimi's residents walk a lot do karaoke
with their neighbors get up early in the
morning and as soon as they've had
breakfast or even before head outside to
weed their gardens
they don't go to the gym or exercise
intensely but they almost never stop
moving in the course of their daily
routines
as easy as getting out of your chair
metabolism slows down 90 after 30
minutes of sitting
the enzymes that move the bad fat from
your arteries to your muscles where it
can get burdened off slow down and after
two hours good cholesterol drops 20
percent
just getting up for five minutes is
going to get things going again
these things are so simple they're
almost stupid
says gavin bradley in a 2015 interview
with bridget schulte for the washington
post
bradley is one of the preeminent experts
on the subject and the director of an
international organization dedicated to
building awareness of how detrimental
sitting all the time can be to our
health
if we live in a city we might find it
hard to move in natural and healthy ways
every day but we can turn to exercises
that have proven for centuries to be
good for the body
the eastern disciplines for bringing
body mind and soul into balance have
become quite popular in the west but in
their countries of origin they've been
used for ages to promote health
yoga originally from india though very
popular in japan and china's qigong and
tai chi among other disciplines seek to
create harmony between a person's body
and mind so they can face the world with
strength joy and serenity
they're touted as elixirs of youth and
science has endorsed the claim
these gentle exercises offer
extraordinary health benefits and are
particularly appropriate for older
individuals who have a harder time
staying fit
tai chi has been shown among other
things to slow the development of
osteoporosis and parkinson's disease to
increase circulation and to improve
muscle tone and flexibility its
emotional benefits are just as important
it's a great shield against stress and
depression
you don't need to go to the gym for an
hour every day or run marathons
as japanese centenarians show us all you
need is to add movement to your day
practicing any of these eastern
disciplines on a regular basis is a
great way to do so
an added benefit is that they all have
well-defined steps and as we heard in
chapter four disciplines with clear
rules are good for flow
if you don't like any of these
disciplines feel free to choose a
practice that you love and that makes
you move
following we'll take a look at some of
the practices that promote health and
longevity but first little appetizer
a singularly japanese exercise for
starting your day
radio tyso
this morning warm-up has been around
since before world war ii
the radio part of its name is from when
the instructions for each exercise were
transmitted over the radio
but today people usually do these
movements while tuned to a television
channel or internet video demonstrating
the steps
one of the main purposes of doing radio
tyso is to promote a spirit of unity
among participants
the exercises are always done in groups
usually in schools before the start of
classes and in businesses before the
work day begins
statistics show that thirty percent of
japanese practice radio tai so for a few
minutes every morning
but radio taiso is one thing that almost
everyone we interviewed in ogimi had in
common
even the residents of the nursing home
we visited dedicated at least five
minutes every day to doing it though
some did the exercises from their
wheelchairs
we joined them on their daily practice
and we felt refreshed for the rest of
the day
when these exercises are done in a group
it's usually on a sports field or in a
large reception hall and typically
involves some kind of loudspeaker
the exercises take five or ten minutes
depending on whether you do all or only
some of them
they focus on dynamic stretching and
increasing joint mobility
one of the most iconic radio tyso
exercises consists of simply raising
your arms above your head and then
bringing them down in a circular motion
it's a tool to wake up the body an easy
mobility workout that is low in
intensity and that focuses on exercising
as many joints as possible
it might seem basic but in our modern
lives we can spend days without raising
our arms above our ears
think about it our arms are down when
using computers when using smartphones
when reading books
one of the few times we raise our hands
over our heads is when reaching for
something in a cupboard or closet
while our ancestors were raising their
hands over their heads all the time when
gathering things from trees
radio tyso helps us to practice all the
basic movements of the body
yoga
popular in japan as well as in the west
yoga can be done by almost anyone some
of its poses have even been adapted for
pregnant women and practitioners with
physical disabilities
yoga comes from india where it was
developed millennia ago to unite our
mental and physical elements
the word yoga itself comes from the
sanskrit term for yok which refers to
the cross piece that binds draft animals
to one another and to the cart they're
pulling
yoga strives to unite body and mind in
the same way
guiding us toward a healthy lifestyle in
harmony with the world around us
the main objectives of yoga are
to bring us closer to our human nature
mental and physical purification
to bring us closer to the divine
styles of yoga
though all are oriented towards similar
goals there are many different types of
yoga that vary according to the
traditions and texts from which they
were developed
the differences among them lie as the
master say in the path taken to the
summit of our best self
jhana yoga
the yoga of wisdom the search for
discipline and mental growth
karma yoga focuses on action on tasks
and duties that benefit oneself and
one's community
bhakti yoga
the yoga of devotion and surrender to
the divine
mantra yoga focuses on the recitation of
mantras to reach a state of relaxation
kundalini yoga combines diverse steps to
reach the desired mental state
raja yoga also known as the royal path
encompasses a range of steps geared
toward achieving communion with oneself
and others
hata yoga
the most widespread form in the west and
japan characterized by asanas or poses
combined in a quest for balance
how to do a sun salutation
the sun salutation is one of the most
iconic exercises in hatha yoga
to do it you simply have to follow these
12 basic movements
one
with your feet together stand up
straight but keep your muscles relaxed
exhale
two
place the palms of your hands together
in front of your chest
from this position inhale as you raise
your arms above your head and bend
backwards slightly
three
exhale as you bend forward until you
touch the ground with the palms of your
hands without bending your knees
four
stretch one leg back to touch the floor
with the tips of your toes
inhale
five
bring the other leg back keeping your
legs and arms straight as you hold your
breath
six
as you exhale bend your arms and bring
your chest to the ground and then
forward resting your knees on the ground
seven
straighten your arms and bend your spine
back keeping the lower half of your body
on the ground
inhale
eight with your hands and feet on the
ground lift your hips until your arms
and legs are straight and your body
forms an upside down v
exhale throughout the movement
nine
bring forward the same leg you'd stretch
back earlier and bend it so that your
knee and foot are aligned under your
head and between your hands
inhale
ten
exhale as you bring your back foot
forward and straighten your legs keeping
your hands on the ground as in posture
three
eleven
bring your arms above your head with
your palms together and bend backwards
slightly as you did in posture two while
you inhale
twelve
lower your arms to their initial
position in mountain pose while you
exhale
you've just greeted the sun
now you're ready to have a fantastic day
tai chi
also known as tai chi chuan tai chi is a
chinese martial art that can be traced
back hundreds of years to buddhism and
confucianism
it's very popular in japan too
according to chinese tradition it was
created by the taoist master and martial
arts practitioner chiang sang thung
though it was yang luchan who in the
19th century brought the form to the
rest of the world
tai chi was originally a negia or
internal martial art meaning its goal
was personal growth
focused on self-defense it teaches those
who practice it to defeat their
adversaries by using the least amount of
force possible and by relying on agility
tai chi which was also seen as a means
of healing body and mind would go on to
be used more frequently to foster health
and inner peace
to encourage its citizens to be more
active the chinese government promoted
it as an exercise and it lost its
original connection to martial arts
becoming instead a source of health and
well-being accessible to all
styles of tai chi
there are different schools and styles
of tai chi the following are the best
known
chen style
alternates between slow movements and
explosive ones
yang style the most widespread of the
forms characterized by slow fluid
movements
wu style
utilizes small slow deliberate movements
how style
centered on internal movements with
almost microscopic external movements
one of the least practiced forms of tai
chi even in china
despite their differences these styles
all have the same objectives
1.
to control movement through stillness
two
to overcome force through finesse
three
to move second and arrive first
four
to know yourself
and your opponent
the ten basic principles of tai chi
according to the master yang chung fu
the correct practice of tai chi follows
ten basic principles
one
elevate the crown of your head and focus
all your energy there
two
tighten your chest and expand your back
to lighten your lower body
three relax your waist and let it guide
your body
four
learn to differentiate between heaviness
and lightness
knowing how your weight is distributed
five
relax the shoulders to allow free
movement of the arms and promote the
flow of energy
six
value the agility of the mind over the
strength of the body
seven unify the upper and lower body so
they act in concert
eight
unify the internal and the external to
synchronize mind body and breath
nine
do not break the flow of your movement
maintain fluidity and harmony
ten
look for stillness in movement
an active body leads to a calm mind
imitating clouds
one of the best known movements in tai
chi consists of following the form of
clouds in an exercise called wave hands
like clouds
here are the steps
one
extend your arms in front of you with
your palms down
two turn your palms to face in as though
you were hugging a tree trunk
three open your arms out to the side
four
bring the left arm up and center and the
right arm down and center
five
trace the shape of a ball in front of
your body
six
turn your left palm toward your face
seven
shift your weight to your left foot and
pivot from your hip toward that side
while your eyes follow the movement of
your hand
eight bring your left hand to your waist
and your right hand in front of your
face
nine
shift your weight to your right foot
ten
pivot toward your right looking at your
raised right hand the entire time
eleven
repeat this movement fluidly shifting
your weight from one foot to the other
as you reposition your hands
twelve
stretch your arms out in front of you
again and bring them down slowly
returning to your initial position
qigong
also known as chi kung
its name combines qi
life force or energy and gong work
indicating that the form works with the
individual's life force
though relatively modern especially
under its current name the art of qigong
is based on the tao yin an ancient art
meant to foster mental and physical
well-being
the practice began to appear in reports
on training and martial arts at the
beginning of the 20th century and by the
1930s was being used in hospitals
the chinese government later popularized
it as it had done with tai chi
qigong involves static and dynamic
physical exercises that stimulate
respiration in a standing seated or
reclined position
there are many different styles of
qigong but all of them seek to
strengthen and regenerate chi
though its movements are typically
gentle the practice is intense
benefits of qigong
according to numerous international
scientific studies qigong like tai chi
and yoga offer significant health
benefits
the following stand out among those
proven through scientific research as
observed by dr kenneth m sanser of san
francisco's qigong institute in his
article medicinal applications of qigong
modification of brain waves
improved balance of sex hormones lower
mortality rate from heart attacks
lower blood pressure in patients with
hypertension
greater bone density
better circulation
deceleration of symptoms associated with
senility
greater balance and efficiency of bodily
functions
increased blood flow to the brain and
greater mind-body connection
improved cardiac function
reduction in the secondary effects of
cancer treatments
practicing these arts not only keeps us
in shape it also helps extend our lives
methods for practicing qigong
in order to practice qigong correctly we
should remember that our life energy
flows through our whole body
we should know how to regulate its many
parts
1.
regulating the body by adopting the
correct posture
it's important to be firmly rooted to
the ground
2.
regulating the breath until it is calm
steady and peaceful
3.
regulating the mind
the most complicated part as it implies
emptying the mind of thoughts
regulating the life force through the
regulation of the three prior elements
so that it flows naturally
5.
regulating the spirit
the spirit is both strength and root in
battle as yang zhuang ming explains in
the essence of taiji qigong
in this way the whole organism will be
prepared to work together toward a
single goal
the five elements of qigong
one of qigong's best known exercises is
a series representing the five elements
earth water wood
metal and fire
this series of movements seeks to
balance the five currents of energy in
order to improve brain and organ
function
there are several ways to do these
movements
in this case we're following the model
of professor maria isabel garcia monreal
from the qigong institute in barcelona
earth 1.
stand with your legs apart and your feet
directly below your shoulders
2.
turn your feet outwards slightly to
straighten the posture
keep your shoulders relaxed and down and
your arms loose at your sides slightly
away from your body
this is the wu chi or rooted posture
four
as you inhale raise your arms in front
of you until your hands are level with
your shoulders your palms facing down
five
exhale as you bend your knees and bring
your arms down until your hands are
level with your stomach your palms
facing in
six
hold this position for a few seconds
focusing on your breath
water
starting from earth posture
bend your knees into a squat keeping
your chest upright and exhaling
throughout
two
press your coccyx downward to stretch
your lumbar spine
three
as you inhale stand to return to earth
posture
four
repeat twice for a total of three
wood
one
starting from earth posture turn your
palms upward and open your arms to the
side forming a circle as you inhale
until your hands are level with your
clavicle
turn your hands so that your palms and
elbows point downward while keeping your
shoulders relaxed
two
reverse the movement as you exhale
making a downward circle with your arms
until you reach your initial position
three
repeat twice for a total of three
metal one
starting from earth posture raise your
arms until your hands are level with
your sternum
two
turn your palms toward each other about
four inches apart with your fingers
relaxed and slightly separated pointing
upward
three
as you inhale move your hands away from
each other until they are shoulder-width
apart
four
as you exhale bring your hands toward
each other until they are back in
position two
five
repeat twice for a total of three
observing the concentration of energy as
you bring your hands together in front
of your lungs
fire
one
starting from earth posture bring your
hands level with your heart as you
inhale with one hand slightly above the
other and your palms facing each other
two
rotate your hands to feel the energy of
your heart
three
turn from your waist gently to the left
keeping your torso relaxed and your
forearms parallel to the ground
four with your palms still facing each
other
separate your hands bringing one up
until it is level with your shoulder and
the other down in front of your abdomen
five
turn from your waist gently to the right
keeping your torso relaxed and your
forearms parallel to the ground
six
as you exhale let your hands come back
together in front of your heart
seven
with your palms still facing each other
separate your hands bringing one up
until it is level with your shoulder and
the other down in front of your abdomen
completing the series
one
starting from earth posture
inhale as you bring your hands level
with your shoulders palms facing down
two
as you exhale
lower your arms to rest at your sides
returning to the initial wu chi posture
shiatsu
created in japan in the early 20th
century principally for the treatment of
arthritis shiatsu also works on energy
flow through the application of pressure
with the thumbs and the palms of the
hands
in combination with stretching and
breathing exercises it seeks to create
equilibrium among the different elements
of the body
the following quote is about the dao yin
a general term referring to the ancient
arts meant to foster mental and physical
well-being
it is not important that a dao yin have
a name he is imitating something or is
engraved in jade
what is important is the technique and
the essence of what is really practiced
stretching and contracting bending and
lifting of the head stepping lying down
resting or standing walking or stepping
slowly screaming or breathing everything
can be a dao yin
breathe better
live longer
the book shu chen shishu known in the
west as 10 books on the cultivation of
perfection dates back to the 13th
century and is a compendium of materials
from diverse sources on developing the
mind and body
it quotes among others the celebrated
chinese doctor and essiest son simeo who
lived during the sixth century
sun simiao was a proponent of a
technique called the six healing sounds
which involves the coordination of
movement breathing and pronouncing
sounds with the purpose of bringing our
souls to a place of calm
the six sounds are
xu
pronounced like shh
with a deep sigh which is associated
with the liver
h e pronounced like her
with a yawn which is associated with the
heart
s i pronounced like sir with a slow
exhale which is associated with the
lungs
c-h-u-i pronounced like tui with a
forceful exhale which is also associated
with the kidneys
h-o-o pronounced like who
which is associated with the spleen and
x-i
pronounced like she
which connects the whole body
the following poem by sun simeow offers
clues about how to live well according
to the season
it reminds us of the importance of
breathing and suggests that as we
breathe we visualize the organs
associated with each of the healing
sounds
in spring breathe shh
for clear eyes and so wood can aid your
liver
in summer reach for her
so that heart and fire can be at peace
in fall breathe
sir
to stabilize and gather metal keeping
the lungs moist
for the kidneys next breathe
and see your inner waters calm
the triple heater needs your she to
expel all heat and troubles
in all four seasons take deep breaths so
your spleen can process food
and of course avoid exhaling noisily
don't let even your own ears hear you
the practice is most excellent and will
help preserve your divine elixir
it might feel confusing to be presented
with all the eastern traditions we've
introduced in this chapter
the takeaway is that they all combine a
physical exercise with an awareness of
our breath
these two components movements and
breath help us to bring our
consciousness in line with our body
instead of allowing our mind to be
carried away by the sea of daily worries
most of the time we're just not aware
enough of our breathing
chapter 9
resilience
and wabi-sabi
how to face life's challenges without
letting stress and worry age you
what is resilience
one thing that everyone with a clearly
defined icky guy has in common is that
they pursue their passion no matter what
they never give up
even when the card seems stacked against
them or they face one hurdle after
another
we're talking about resilience
a concept that's become influential
among psychologists
but resilience isn't just the ability to
persevere
as we'll hear in this chapter it's also
an outlook we can cultivate to stay
focused on the important things in life
rather than what is most urgent and keep
ourselves from being carried away by
negative emotions
in the final section of the chapter
we'll explore techniques that go beyond
resilience to cultivate anti-fragility
sooner or later we all have to face
difficult moments and the way we do this
can make a huge difference to our
quality of life
proper training for our mind body and
emotional resilience is essential for
confronting life's ups and downs
fall seven times
rise eight
japanese proverb
resilience is our ability to deal with
setbacks the more resilient we are the
easier it will be to pick ourselves up
and get back to what gives meaning to
our lives
resilient people know how to stay
focused on their objectives on what
matters without giving into
discouragement
their flexibility is the source of their
strength they know how to adapt to
change into reversals of fortune they
concentrate on the things they can
control and don't worry about those they
can't
in the words of the famous serenity
prayer by reinhold nibir
god give us grace to accept with
serenity the things that cannot be
changed
courage to change the things which
should be changed
and the wisdom to distinguish the one
from the other
emotional resilience through buddhism
and stoicism
siddhartha gautama buddha was born a
prince of kapilavas to nepal and grew up
in a palace surrounded by riches
at 16 he married and had a child
satisfied by his family's wealth
he decided to try a different lifestyle
and ran away from the palace to live as
an ascetic
but it wasn't asceticism that he was
looking for
it didn't offer the happiness and
well-being he sought
neither wealth nor extreme asceticism
worked for him
he realized that a wise person should
not ignore life's pleasures
a wise person can live with these
pleasures but should always remain
conscious of how easy it is to be
enslaved by them
zeno obsidium began his studies with the
cynics
the cynics also led ascetic lives
leaving behind all earthly pleasures
they lived in the street and the only
thing they owned was the clothing on
their backs
seeing that cynicism did not give him a
sense of well-being zeno abandoned its
teachings to found the school of
stoicism which centers on the idea that
there is nothing wrong with enjoying
life's pleasures as long as they do not
take control of your life as you enjoy
them
you have to be prepared for those
pleasures to disappear
the goal is not to eliminate all
feelings and pleasures from our lives as
in cynicism but to eliminate negative
emotions
since their inception one of the
objectives of both buddhism and stoicism
has been to control pleasure emotions
and desires
though the philosophies are very
different both aim to curb our ego and
control our negative emotions
both stoicism and buddhism are at the
roots methods for practicing well-being
according to stoicism our pleasures and
desires are not the problem we can enjoy
them as long as they don't take control
of us
the stoics viewed those who were able to
control their emotions as virtuous
what's the worst thing that could happen
we finally land our dream job
but after a little while we're already
hunting for a better one
we win the lottery and buy a nice car
but then decide we can't live without a
sailboat
we finally win the heart of the man or
woman we've been pining for then
suddenly we find we have a wandering eye
people can be insatiable
the stoics believe that these kinds of
desires and ambitions are not worth
pursuing
the objective of the virtuous person is
to reach a state of tranquility
apathy
the absence of negative feelings such as
anxiety fear shame vanity and anger and
the presence of positive feelings such
as happiness love serenity and gratitude
in order to keep their minds virtuous
the stoics practiced something like
negative visualization
they imagine the worst thing that could
happen in order to be prepared if
certain privileges and pleasures were
taken from them
to practice negative visualization we
have to reflect on negative events but
without worrying about them
seneca one of the richest men in ancient
rome lived a life of luxury but was
nonetheless an active stoic
he recommended practicing negative
visualization every night before falling
asleep
in fact he not only imagined these
negative situations he actually put them
into practice
for example by living for a week without
servants or the food and drink he was
used to as a wealthy man
as a result he was able to answer the
question what's the worst thing that
could happen
meditating for healthier emotions
in addition to negative visualization
and not giving into negative emotions
another central tenet of stoicism is
knowing what we can control and what we
can't as we see in the serenity prayer
worrying about things that are beyond
our control accomplishes nothing
we should have a clear sense of what we
can change and what we can't which in
turn will allow us to resist giving in
to negative emotions
in the words of epictetus
it's not what happens to you but how you
react that matters
in zen buddhism meditation is a way to
become aware of our desires and emotions
and thereby free ourselves from them
it's not simply a question of keeping
the mind free of thoughts but instead
involves observing our thoughts and
emotions as they appear without getting
carried away by them
in this way we train our minds not to
get swept up in anger jealousy or
resentment
one of the most commonly used mantras in
buddhism focuses on controlling negative
emotions
[Music]
in which om is the generosity that
purifies the ego
ma
is the ethics that purifies jealousy
ni is the patience that purifies passion
and desire
pod
is the precision that purifies bias
is the surrender that purifies greed and
whom
is the wisdom that purifies hatred
the here and now and the impermanence of
things
another key to cultivating resilience is
knowing in which time to live
both buddhism and stoicism remind us
that the present is all that exists
and it is the only thing we can control
instead of worrying about the past or
the future we should appreciate things
just as they are in the moment in the
now
the only moment in which you can be
truly alive is the present moment
observes the buddhist monk tiknot han
in addition to living in the here and
now the stoics recommend reflecting on
the impermanence of the things around us
the roman emperor marcus aurelius said
that the things we love are like the
leaves of a tree
they can fall at any moment with the
gust of wind
he also said that changes in the world
around us are not accidental but rather
form part of the essence of the universe
a rather buddhist notion in fact
we should never forget that everything
we have and all the people we love will
disappear at some point this is
something we should keep in mind but
without giving in to pessimism
being aware of the impermanence of
things does not have to make us sad
it should help us love the present
moment and those who surround us
all things human are short-lived and
perishable
seneca tells us
the temporary ephemeral and impermanent
nature of the world is central to every
buddhist discipline
keeping this always in mind helps us
avoid excessive pain in times of loss
wabi-sabi and ichigo ichie
wabi-sabi is a japanese concept that
shows us the beauty of the fleeting
changeable and imperfect nature of the
world around us
instead of searching for beauty in
perfection we should look forward in
things that are flawed incomplete
this is why the japanese place such
value for example on an irregular or
cracked teacup
only things that are imperfect
incomplete and ephemeral can truly be
beautiful
because only those things resemble the
natural world
a complementary japanese concept is that
of ichigo ichie
which could be translated as this moment
exists only now and won't come again
it's heard most often in social
gatherings as a reminder that each
encounter whether with friends family or
strangers is unique and will never be
repeated
meaning that we should enjoy the moment
and not lose ourselves and worries about
the past or the future
the concept is commonly used in tea
ceremonies zen meditation and japanese
martial arts all of which place emphasis
on being present in the moment
in the west we've grown accustomed to
the permanence of the stone buildings
and cathedrals of europe which sometimes
gives us the sense that nothing changes
making us forget about the passage of
time
greco-roman architecture adores symmetry
sharp lines imposing facades and
buildings and statues of the gods that
outlast the centuries
japanese architecture on the other hand
doesn't try to be imposing or perfect
because it is built in the spirit of
wabi-sabi
the tradition of making structures out
of wood presupposes their impermanence
and the need for future generations to
rebuild them
japanese culture accepts the fleeting
nature of the human being and everything
we create
the grand shrine of isa for example has
been rebuilt every twenty years for
centuries
the most important thing is not to keep
the building standing for generations
but to preserve customs and traditions
things that can withstand the passage of
time better than structures made by
human hands
the key is to accept that there are
certain things over which we have no
control like the passage of time and the
ephemeral nature of the world around us
ichigo ichie teaches us to focus on the
present and enjoy each moment that life
brings us
this is why it's so important to find
and pursue our ikigai
wabi-sabi teaches us to appreciate the
beauty of imperfection as an opportunity
for growth
beyond resilience
anti-fragility
as the legend goes the first time
hercules faced the hydra he despaired
when he discovered that cutting off one
of its heads meant that two would grow
back in its place
he would never be able to kill the beast
if it got stronger with every wound
as nasim nicholas talib explains in
antifragile things that gain from
disorder
we use the word fragile to describe
people things and organizations that are
weakened when harmed and the words
robust and resilient for things that are
able to withstand harm without weakening
but we don't have a word for things that
get stronger when harmed up to a point
to refer to the kind of power possessed
by the hydra of lerna to talk about
things that get stronger when they are
harmed talib proposed the term
anti-fragile
anti-fragility is beyond resilience or
robustness
the resilient resists shocks and stays
the same
the anti-fragile gets better
catastrophes and exceptional
circumstances offer good models for
explaining anti-fragility
in 2011 a tsunami hit the tohoku region
of japan doing tremendous damage to
dozens of cities and towns along the
coast most famously fukushima
when we visited the affected coast two
years after the catastrophe having
driven for hours along cracked highways
and passed one empty gas station after
another
we passed through several ghost towns
whose streets had been taken over by the
remnants of houses piles of cars and
empty train stations
these towns were fragile spaces that had
been forgotten by the government and
could not recover on their own
other places such as ishinomaki and
kisinnuma suffered extensive damage but
were rebuilt within a few years thanks
to the efforts of many
ishinomaki and kisanuma showed how
resilient they were in their ability to
return to normal after the catastrophe
the earthquake that caused the tsunami
also affected the fukushima nuclear
power plant
the tokyo electric power company
engineers working at the plant were not
prepared to recover from that kind of
damage
the fukushima nuclear facility is still
in a state of emergency and will be for
decades to come
it demonstrated its fragility in the
face of an unprecedented catastrophe
the japanese financial markets closed
minutes after the earthquake
which businesses did the best in the
aftermath
stock and big construction companies has
been steadily on the rise since 2011.
the need to rebuild the entire coast of
tohoku is a boon for construction
in this case japanese construction
companies are anti-fragile since they
benefited enormously from the
catastrophe
now let's take a look at how we can
apply this concept to our daily lives
how can we be more anti-fragile
step one
create redundancies
instead of having a single salary try to
find a way to make money from your
hobbies at other jobs or by starting
your own business
if you have only one salary you might be
left with nothing should your employer
run into trouble leaving you in a
position of fragility
on the other hand if you have several
options and you lose your primary job it
might just happen that you end up
dedicating more time to your secondary
job and maybe even make more money at it
you would have beaten that stroke of bad
luck and would be in that case
antifragile
one hundred percent of the seniors we
interviewed in oguimi had a primary and
secondary occupation
most of them kept a vegetable garden as
a secondary job and sold their produce
at the local market
the same idea goes for friendships and
personal interests
it's just a matter as the saying goes of
not putting all your eggs in one basket
in the sphere of romantic relationships
there are those who focus all their
energy on their partner and make him or
her their whole world
those people lose everything if the
relationship doesn't work out
whereas if they've cultivated strong
friendships and a full life along the
way they'll be in a better position to
move on at the end of a relationship
they'll be anti-fragile
right now you might be thinking i don't
need more than one salary and i'm happy
with the friends i've always had why
should i add anything new
it might seem like a waste of time to
add variation to our lives because
extraordinary things don't ordinarily
happen
we slip into a comfort zone
but the unexpected always happens
sooner or later
step two
bet conservatively in certain areas and
take many small risks in others
the world of finance turns out to be
very useful in explaining this concept
if you have ten thousand dollars saved
up you might put nine thousand dollars
of that into an index fund or fixed term
deposit and invest the remaining one
thousand dollars in ten startups with
huge growth potential say one hundred
dollars in each
one possible scenario is that three of
the companies fail
you lose three hundred dollars
the value of three other companies goes
down you lose another one or two hundred
dollars the value of three goes up you
make one or two hundred dollars and the
value of one of the startups increases
twentyfold
you make nearly two thousand dollars or
maybe even more
you still make money even if three of
the businesses go completely belly up
you've benefited from the damage just
like the hydra
the key to becoming antifragile is
taking on small risks that might lead to
great reward without exposing ourselves
to dangers that might sink us such as
investing ten thousand dollars in a fund
of questionable reputation that we saw
advertised in the newspaper
step three
get rid of the things that make you
fragile
we're taking the negative route for this
exercise
ask yourself what makes me fragile
certain people things and habits
generate losses for us and make us
vulnerable
who and what are they
when we make our new year's resolutions
we tend to emphasize adding new
challenges to our lives
it's great to have this kind of
objective but setting good written
skulls can have an even bigger impact
for example
stop snacking between meals
eat sweets only once a week
gradually pay off all debt
avoid spending time with toxic people
avoid spending time doing things we
don't enjoy simply because we feel
obligated to do them
spend no more than 20 minutes on
facebook each day
to build resilience into our lives we
shouldn't fear adversity because each
setback is an opportunity for growth
if we adopt an anti-fragile attitude
we'll find a way to get stronger with
every blow
refining our lifestyle and staying
focused on our icky guy
taking a hit or two can be viewed as
either a misfortune or an experience
that we can apply to all areas of our
lives as we continually make corrections
and set new and better goals
as talab writes in anti-fragile
we need randomness mess adventures
uncertainty self-discovery
here traumatic episodes
all these things that make life worth
living
we encourage those interested in the
concept of anti-fragility to read nasim
nicholas talibs anti-fragile
life is pure imperfection as the
philosophy of wabi-sabi teaches us
and the passage of time shows us that
everything is fleeting
but if you have a clear sense of your
ikigai
each moment will hold so many
possibilities that it will seem almost
like an eternity
epilogue
ikigai
the art of living
mitsuo aida was one of the most
important calligraphers and haikuists of
the 20th century
he is yet another example of a japanese
person who dedicated his life to a very
specific ikigai
communicating emotions with seventeen
syllable poems using a shodo calligraphy
brush
many of aida's haikus philosophize about
the importance of the present moment and
the passage of time
one could be translated as
in the here and now the only thing in my
life is your life
in another poem aida writes simply
here
now
it is an artwork that seeks to evoke
feelings of mana no aware
a melancholy appreciation of the
ephemeral
the following poem touches on one of the
secrets of bringing ikigai into our
lives
happiness is always determined by your
heart
and one last one also by aida is
keep going
don't change your path
once you discover your ikigai pursuing
it and nurturing it every day will bring
meaning to your life
the moment your life has this purpose
you will achieve a happy state of flow
in all you do
like the calligrapher does canvas or the
chef who after half a century still
prepares sushi for his patrons with love
conclusion
our ikigai is different for all of us
but one thing we have in common is that
we're all searching for meaning
when we spend our days feeling connected
to what is meaningful to us we live more
fully
when we lose the connection we feel
despair
modern life estranges us more and more
from our true nature making it very easy
for us to lead lives lacking in meaning
powerful forces and incentives money
power attention success
distract us on a daily basis
don't let them take over your life
our intuition and curiosity are very
powerful internal compasses to help us
connect with our hiki guy
follow those things you enjoy and get
away from or change those you dislike
be led by your curiosity and keep busy
by doing things that fill you with
meaning and happiness
it doesn't need to be a big thing
we might find meeting and being good
parents or in helping our neighbors
there is no perfect strategy to
connecting with our achy guy
but what we've learned from the
okinawans is that we should not worry
too much about finding it
life is not a problem to be solved
just remember to have something that
keeps you busy doing what you love while
being surrounded by the people who love
you
the ten rules of ikigai
we'll conclude this journey with 10
rules we've distilled from the wisdom of
the long-lived residents of oguimi
1.
stay active don't retire
those who give up the things they love
doing and do well lose their purpose in
life
that's why it's so important to keep
doing things of value making progress
bringing beauty or utility to others
helping out and shaping the world around
you even after your official
professional activity has ended
two
take it slow
being in a hurry is inversely
proportional to quality of life
as the old saying goes walk slowly and
you'll go far
when we leave urgency behind
life and time take on new meaning
three
don't fill your stomach
less is more when it comes to eating for
long life too
according to the eighty percent rule in
order to stay healthier longer we should
eat a little less than our hunger
demands instead of stuffing ourselves
four
surround yourself with good friends
friends are the best medicine
there for confiding worries over a good
chat sharing stories that brighten your
day getting advice having fun dreaming
in other words living
five
get in shape for your next birthday
water moves it is at its best when it
flows fresh and doesn't stagnate
the body you move through life in needs
a bit of daily maintenance to keep it
running for a long time
plus exercise releases hormones that
make us feel happy
six
smile
a cheerful attitude is not only relaxing
it also helps make friends
it's good to recognize the things that
aren't so great but we should never
forget what a privilege it is to be in
the here and now in a world so full of
possibilities
7.
reconnect with nature
though most people live in cities these
days human beings are made to be part of
the natural world
we should return to it often to recharge
our batteries
eight
give thanks
to your ancestors to nature which
provides you with the air you breathe in
the food you eat
to your friends and family to everything
that brightens your days and makes you
feel lucky to be alive
spend a moment every day giving thanks
and you'll watch your stockpile of
happiness grow
nine
live in the moment
stop regretting the past and fearing the
future
today is all you have
make the most of it
make it worth remembering
10.
follow your ikigai
there is a passion inside you
a unique talent that gives meaning to
your days and drives you to share the
very best of yourself until the very end
if you don't know what your ikigai is
yet as viktor frankl says your mission
is to discover it
the authors of this audiobook wish you a
long happy and purposeful life
thank you for joining us
hector garcia and francesc miraez
you've been listening to ikigai the
japanese secret to a long and happy life
by hector garcia and francesc marias
narrated by walter dixon
if you've enjoyed this audiobook and
this performance then please visit our
website
gildanmedia.com that's
g-i-l-d-a-n-m-e-d-i-a-dot-com
where you'll find a wide selection of
titles in business and finance personal
development psychology and much much
more
and thank you for being a gildan audio
listener
[Music]
this has been a gildan audio production
for more affordable mind enriching
programs
visit our website at gildanmedia.com
you